INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
AND ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES ON FAMILY SEPARATIONS
AT THE BORDER AND HOW
CALIFORNIA CAN FURTHER SUPPORT
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES. I WANT TO
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. TO START I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK ALL THE STAFF
THAT HAVE MADE POSSIBLE ARE
RETURNED THE CAPITAL AND OUR
ABILITY TO MAXIMIZE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARTICIPATION
IN OUR HEARING. DUE TO THE
CONTINUED STAY HOME ORDER. WE
ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER. AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. WE ARE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN PERSON. TODAY IN THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC.
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN.
TO BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY DURING
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS TWO FOUR TWO.
SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU WERE
CALLING INTO MAKE A STATEMENT
DURING PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MEETING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE. TWO ZERO EIGHT NINE
AND MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO
TRY AND HELP. THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ADOPTED AND IMPLEMENTED A ZERO
TOLERANCE POLICY POLICY FOR
CERTAIN IMMIGRATION OFFENSES.
AND THE WORLD WATCHED ON IS
THIS POLICY RESULTED IN THE
FORCED SEPARATION OF THOUSANDS
OF MIGRANT FAMILIES AT THE
BORDER. THE RESULTING TRAUMA AT
THE SEPARATIONS COUPLED WITH
THE CONFUSION OF NAVIGATING OUR
COUNTRY'S COMPLEX IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM. HAS UNDERSCORED THE
NEED TO PROVIDE FOR THE
MOTIONAL CULTURAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF THESE FAMILIES.
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG BEEN A
LEADER IN SUPPORTING OUR
IMMIGRANT POPULATION. AND HAS
IMPLEMENTED A NUMBER OF
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS AND TO
PROVIDING FOR THEIR LEGAL
EDUCATION AND HEALTHY. WELL
COURT ORDERS HAVE MANDATED THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REUNIFY.
AND PROVIDE FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF FAMILIES
SEPARATED AT THE BORDER. THERE
IS STILL MUCH WORK TO BE DONE
TO ENSURE THAT THE SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR IMMIGRANT
POPULATION ARE ADEQUATE. AND
PROVIDE FOR THEIR UNIQUE
EXPERIENCES AND CULTURAL NEEDS.
AT TODAY'S HEARING WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN ABOUT
THE HISTORY OF FAMILY
SEPARATIONS. CALIFORNIA'S ROLE
IN ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. AND HOW FORCED FAMILY
SEPARATIONS CAN RESULT IN
TRAUMA AND LIFELONG FF. WE WILL
ALSO HEAR FROM ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE WORKING TO PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF CHILDREN AND FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION CAPACITY. THAT ARE
WORKING TO LOCATE AND REUNIFY
FAMILIES THAT REMAIN SEPARATED.
AND ARE WORKING TO CONTINUE TO
COORDINATE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR THESE FAMILIES.
FINALLY WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR HOW
CALIFORNIA. AND THE LEGISLATURE
CAN FURTHER SUPPORT OUR
IMMIGRANT POPULATION. AS WELL
AS ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE DOING
THE DIFFICULT AND TREMENDOUS
WORK OF SERVING THE FAMILIES.
THANK YOU ALL FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO JOIN US. AT THIS TIME
I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE GERMAN
STONE FOR ANY OPENING REMARKS
YOU MAY WISH TO CONTRIBUTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. VERY
HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY. AND
LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR PUTTING TOGETHER A
GREAT BACKGROUND PAPER THAT
REALLY LAYS OUT. THE ISSUES
THAT WE'VE SEEN HERE. THIS
LEGISLATURE BOTH YOUR COMEDIAN
MINE SEEN A NUMBER OF BILLS GO
THROUGH TRYING TO PROTECT.
PEOPLE AT OUR BORDERS. AND YET
CALIFORNIA HAVING TO STEP UP
AND SPEND MONEY. REALLY IN
RESPONSE TO FAIL FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION POLICY REGRESSION
POLICY THAT LEAVES FAMILIES AND
KIDS SEPARATED AT THE BORDER.
THESE CHILDREN CAGES SET UP IN
HUMANE AND UNACCEPTABLE
SITUATIONS SO FOR US TO TAKE A
LOOK AT. WHAT THE REALITIES ON
THE GROUND. TO TRY AND MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE. COMING AND
GOING THE CALIFORNIA AND IN
PEOPLE WHO. OUR ECONOMY REALLY
RELIES ON OUR ECONOMY OUR
COMMUNITIES FUNCTION BECAUSE OF.
THE IMMIGRANTS WHO COME. AND
WEBER FIELDS AND WORK IN OUR
HOTELS AND WORK. IN OUR
RESTAURANTS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY. IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE A
BABY BENFORD GENERATIONS PART
PARCEL OF REALLY WHO CALIFORNIA
IS AND BECAUSE OF A FAILURE
FEDERAL POLICY IN A BLACK ON
WILLING TO WRECK. WHAT THREE IS
FOR CALIFORNIA AND MANY OF THE
BORDER STATES WE HAVING TO STEP
IN AND ENSURE THAT WE'RE
PROTECTING PEOPLE. WHO ARE
COMING INTO OUR FAIR STATE AND-
OFTEN VERY GOOD REASON. SO
UNTIL THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CHANGES TO POLICIES AND I'M
HOPEFUL THE NEW ADMINISTRATION
WILL DO THAT. AND REALLY
DEMILITARIZED IS CUSTOMS AND
IMMIGRATION AND PUTS IT BACK TO
AN ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTION THAT
IT HAD BEEN FOR GENERATIONS AND
SUDDENLY IT BECOMES A
PARAMILITARY FORCE THAT IS MORE
INTENT ON KEEPING PEOPLE OUT.
TREATING PEOPLE AS- WE WOULD
NEVER WANT TO SEE PEOPLE BEING
TREATED. UNTIL THAT CHANGES
WE'RE GOING TO STILL CONTINUE
TO NEED TO STEP UP AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT RESOURCES AND POLICIES
WE CAN BRING TO BEAR. TO HELP
THESE PEOPLE OUT. TO THE BEST
EXTENT THAT WE POSSIBLY CAN TO
LOOK FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSION
TODAY LOOK FORWARD. TO THE
WITNESSES NORMALLY IN A HEARING
LIKE THIS WE WOULD HAVE.
WITNESSES ON HAS A STABLE SIDES
ARE ALL SIGNS. BUT I DON'T KNOW
WHO WOULD BE. TO DO. THE
INHUMANE POLICIES HAVE PUT US
IN THE CITY. SO I LOOK FORTY
HEARING FROM SPEAKERS. AND WHAT
MAKES STEPS WHAT MORE WE CAN DO
EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE BEEN TRYING
TO LAST FEW TO DO OUR BEST TO
FOR TO SEE WHAT MORE WE CAN DO.
TO PROTECT PEOPLE COMING IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
SOUTH I BEFORE I OPEN IT UP TO
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'D
ALSO LIKE TO INVITE MAJORITY
LEADER REYES TO MAKE ANY
OPENING REMARKS AS A FORMER
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE. MAJORITY
LEADER REYES HAS BEEN A
CHAMPION FOR CALIFORNIA MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. THANK
YOU SO. THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
CHAIR. I DO WANT TO THANK BOTH
OF YOU FOR PUTTING ON THIS SUCH
AN IMPORTANT HEARING AND FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK AT THIS
TIME ON THIS YEAR. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT FAMILY SEPARATION IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE NOT TO BRING UP THE
RACIST AND HATEFUL MESSAGES.
THAT HAVE BEEN SENT TO OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES. YOU DO
NOT BELONG HERE. I THINK WE IN
THE LATINO COMMUNITY HAVE HEARD
THIS MESSAGE SO MANY TIMES
WE'VE HEARD ALL THE HORRIBLE
THINGS THAT HAVE HAPPENED
BECAUSE OF THIS POLICY BUT IT
BEARS REPEATING AGAIN. NOT JUST
BECAUSE IT'S A RACIST POLICY
BUT JUST. NOT JUST BECAUSE OF
THE BAD POLICY BUT BECAUSE IT'S
A MORAL FAILURE. FOR A COUNTRY.
WE ESTIMATE THAT AS A RESULT OF
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S
POLICY. OVER TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
CHILDREN WERE SEPARATED FROM
THEIR FAMILIES. THE STAFF
REPORT MENTIONED THAT IN MY
FULL CHILDREN INCLUDING BABIES
WERE HELD IN DEPLORABLE AND
UNSANITARY CONDITIONS AND QUOTE.
60% OF THE CHILDREN THAT WERE
IMPACTED BY THIS POLICY WERE
UNDER THE AGE OF FIVE. THESE
CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE
OUR NEIGHBORS OUR FRIENDS
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY. IT'S
SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NOT ONLY
ALLOW THIS TO HAPPEN BUT
ACTIVELY ENCOURAGED IT. MUCH
HAS TO BE DONE TO ADDRESS THE
HARM DONE. BUT CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO PRIORITIZE SUPPORTING
REUNITING THESE FAMILIES WHO
ARE HERE SEEKING ASYLUM A LEGAL
REQUEST. AND THAT'S WHY I WANT
TO SHARE THAT I HAVE MOVED TO
INTRODUCED AB FORTY SEVEN WHICH
WOULD COORDINATE SUPPORT OF
SERVICES AND LINK EXISTING
RESOURCES TO FAMILIES WHO WERE
SEPARATED AT THE BORDER. MUST
CONTINUE TO DO WHATEVER WE CAN
TO ASSIST FAMILIES WHO HAVE
BEEN AFFETED BY FAMILY
SEPARATION AND I THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THIS JOINT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. THANK YOU MADAM
MAJORITY LEADER. AT THIS TIME
I'D LIKE TO INVITE ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO MAKE
OPENING REMARKS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND ALSO TO
OUR- OUR OTHER CHAIR- THANK YOU
FOR PUTTING IS VERY IMPORTANT
HEARING ON- THIS ONE ECHO SOME
OF THE COMMENTS THAT A MAJORITY
LEADER HAD ALREADY INDICATED-
YOU KNOW AMERICA HAS A VERY
CHECKERED PAST BECAUSE- I CAN
REMEMBER GOING BACK IN HISTORY.
WHERE AFRICAN AMERICAN-
CHILDREN WERE TAKEN AWAY AND
SOLD INTO SLAVERY- AND THEN WE
HAVE WHAT'S GOING ON HERE IN
THIS COUNTRY WHERE WE HAVE.
KIDS BEING TAKEN AWAY FROM THE
PARENTS AND BEING PLACED IN
CAGES IN A VERY INHUMANE KIND
OF TREATMENT. AND WE HOPE THAT
THIS THIS HISTORY WHEN EVERY
REPEATED AGAIN THAT'S WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO THE KIND
OF HARD WORK THE HEAVY LIFTING
TO MAKING SURE THIS DOESN'T
HAPPEN EVER AGAIN IN THIS
COUNTRY AGAIN. AND SO IT IS TO
THAT END THAT I'M EXCITED ABOUT
THIS TOPIC I'M EXCITED- THAT
WE'RE TAKING ON THE WHOLE TOPIC
SO THAT WE CAN ONE LET
CALIFORNIANS KNOW THAT WE'RE
GOING TO LEAD THE WAY IN THE
SPACE BUT ALSO MAKING SURE THAT
WE WRITE A NEW NARRATIVE MOVING
FORWARD. WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO
IMMIGRATION AND ALSO THE DREAM
OF OUR CHILDREN AND I WANT TO
GET TO ASK QUESTIONS OF OUR
PANELISTS- BECAUSE THEY'RE
STILL MISSING CHILDREN WHO ARE
DISPLACED WHO ARE NOT CONNECTS
THEIR FAMILIES AND TO THEIR TO
THEIR PARENTS THAT I'M QUITE
CONCERNED WITH AND SO. I WANT
TO JUST SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION IS
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU FAMILY
MEMBERS SAN. MANY OF THE OF
OKAY ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS PER
REMOTE THAT WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
A REMARKS. SHARE. CHECK
CALDERON ARE NOT ON IDEA OVER
THERE YES YES GO HEAD OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU LOGICAL AND-
CHAIRS. TRICKING ME INTO SOME
HERE FOR AS WELL J. FROM
EXPERTS IN WHAT SAYS. AND I
JUST WANNA HI SOME OF THE
COMMON FROM A CHAIR STONE
PARTICULARLY- TO HOW I SAYS CAN
NOT DO IT ITSELF OVER THE YEAR.
I MOST WAS. ABOUT HOW FAMILIES
HAVE BEEN APART- AND ONE I
WANTED TO KNOW THAT COSTA RICA
WHY. THE FIRST ACTION I TO IN
THIS LESS. SESSION WAS TO DO A
RUSSELL. CALL ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO ABOUT ICE. THESE
BECOME A PRO. AGENCY WITHIN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THAT BEING
SAID THANK YOU YOU TOO LOW
CHAIRS AND TWENTY MEMBERS FOR
COMING TOGETHER ON THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS.
OKAY THANK YOU- OKAY THERE WILL
BE THREE PANELS OF EXPERTS- THE
FIRST PANEL PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF FAMILY SEPARATION THE STATE
EFFORTS IN THIS AREA AND THE
EFFECTS OF FAMILY SEPARATION ON
FAMILIES THE SECOND PANEL SPEAK
TO EFFORTS TO SUPPORT IMMIGRANT
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND THE
FINAL PANEL ADDRESSED THE
ONGOING NEEDS OF THESE
FAMILIES. I WANT TO PLEASE HOLD
QUESTIONS UNTIL THE END OF THE
PRESENTATION OF EACH PANEL. WE
WILL NOW TURN TO OUR FIRST
SPEAKER DAN THE WINDOW WITH THE
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
IMMIGRATIONS RIGHTS PROJECT.
WELCOME DANCE. HI THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME IT'S NICE TO BE HERE
AT LEAST TO BE VIRTUALLY BACK
IN CALIFORNIA. I AM A STAFF
ATTORNEY IN THE IMMIGRANTS
RIGHTS PROJECT THE ACLU FOR THE
LAST TWO AND A HALF YEARS I
HAVE WORKED ON- THE MISS
ELAPIDAE GEISHA- THE LAWSUIT
THAT FORCED THE GOVERNMENT TO
REUNIFY THOUSANDS OF MIGRANT
FAMILIES. AND DECLARED THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S POLICIES
UNCONSTITUTIONAL- TODAY WE KNOW
THAT MORE THAN FIFTY FIVE
HUNDRED FAMILIES WERE RIPPED
APART BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION. WE KNOW
FAMILIES WERE SEPARATED EVEN
MORE APPARENT WAS NEVER
PROSECUTED FOR A CRIME ANY FOR
THE FAMILY PRESENTED ITSELF TO
A PORT OF ENTRY INSIDE A SILO.
WE KNOWN AND THE GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS KNEW AT THE TIME.
THAT THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
AND NO CONFIDENT WAY TO KEEP
TRACK OF THE SEPARATIONS AND
SELECTED. ORATORY UNIFY
FAMILIES QUICKLY. EVERY STEP OF
TRYING TO HELP THESE FAMILIES
HAVE BEEN MADE HARDER. BY THE
CHAOS AND CRUELTY OF THIS
POLICY. A COVER THREE TOPICS
FIRST A TIMELINE FOR THIS BILL
POLICY IN CONTEXT FOR HOW IT
MARKED A DRASTIC CHANGE. SECOND
OF THE CURRENT STATE OF EFFORTS
TO CONTACT HELP FAMILIES
STUDENTS L. AND THIRD A QUICK
MENTION OF KEY STEPS THAT WE
HAVE ASKED THE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION TO TAKE. BUT TO
UNDERSTAND HOW RARE SEPARATING
A CHILD FROM THEIR PARENTS USED
TO BE. LESS THAN A THIRD OF 1%
OF ALL CHILDREN REFERRED TO THE
CARE THE OFFICE OF REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT. WHICH CHILDREN
SEPARATED FROM PARENTS AS OF
TWENTY SIXTEEN. PRIOR TO THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION. WHEN
SEPARATIONS HAPPEN IN THAT ERA
IT WAS FOR A MEDICALEMERGENCY
FOR EXAMPLE OR THE RARE CASE OF
APPARENT PROPOSED A CURRENT
THREATS TO THEIR CHILD'S. THE
OF SEPARATED CHILDREN- ARE ARE-
INCREASED MORE THAN TENFOLD IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ALONE. THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION BEGAN
EFFORTS TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE PROSECUTED FOR
ILLEGAL ENTRY OR RE ENTRY. TO
TRY TO TIE THE PROGRAM A SUCH
PROSECUTIONS IN THE EL PASO
SECTOR THE RESULTANT
SEPARATIONS A FAMILY. THEN
ATTORNEY GENERAL SESSIONS AND
HIS. BUT SOME OF THAT ATTORNEY
GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS AND HIS
OFFICE DROVE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION SEPARATION
POLICY IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT'S THE
RECENT CONCLUSION OF A
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE INSPECTOR
GENERAL REPORT. THAT REPORT- AS
JUST ONE EXAMPLE RELYING ON THE
NOTES OF SEVERAL PROSECUTORS AT
A TWENTY EIGHTEEN. MAY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN MEETING QUOTED SESSION
SAYING TO THE PROSECUTORS QUOTE
WE NEED TO TAKE AWAY CHILDREN.
SHE WOULD GO ON TO ANNOUNCE THE
FORMAL ZERO TOLERANCE POLICY-
IN MAY OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHICH
RELIED ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY TO REFER AS
MANY ADULTS AS POSSIBLE FOR
PROSECUTION. WHICH THEN LEADS
THEIR CHILDREN BEING TAKEN FROM
THEM WHILE IT WAS BEING
PROSECUTED AND THEN THE
SUBSEQUENT ORDEALS OF
ATTEMPTING TO UNIFY AND GET
THESE FAMILIES BACK TOGETHER-
MEANWHILE WE WERE LITIGATING
MISS L. AND A MONTH LATER IN
JUNE OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
JUDGE IN THAT CASE. ORDERED THE
GOVERNMENT TO REUNITE FAMILIES
AND DECLARED THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S POLICIES.
PRACTICES UNCONSTITUTIONAL
CALLING THEM BRUTAL AND HOLDING
THAT THAT SHOCKS- CHECKS THE
CONSCIENCE. POINT OF ALL THE
CHILDREN STILL IN OR CARE
NEARLY A QUARTER OF THEM WERE
CHILDREN WHO HAVE BEEN
SEPARATED FROM A PARENT. NOW I
SAID EARLIER THE TOTAL NUMBER
THIS POINT IS MORE THAN FIFTY
FIVE HUNDRED- IT INCLUDES ABOUT
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED THEN IN
GOVERNMENT CARE. ACCORDING TO
SELL HAD ORDERED TO BE
REUNIFIED IN JUNE OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. BUT IT ALSO INCLUDES
TWO OTHER GROUPS. ONE IS THE
OLDEST SEPARATIONS WHERE THE
CHILDREN WERE ALREADY OUT OF
GOVERNMENT CARE BY THE TIME OF
THE JUDGE'S ORDER. THAT GROUP
WAS REVEALED ONLY LATE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN AFTER INSPECTOR
GENERAL REPORTS AND AFTER THE
WAR IN MICELLE REQUIRED THE
GOVERNMENT TO ACCOUNTS WITH
THEM. THIS GROUP IS FIFTEEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX CHILDREN
AND FINDING THEM AND THEIR
PARENTS HAS BEEN MUCH OF THE
FOCUS OF OUR CURRENT WORK.
THEY'RE ALSO SEPARATIONS AFTER.
THE JUNE TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
JUNCTION. SO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION PURSUED
SEPARATIONS EVEN AFTER THE
COURT'S INJUNCTION DOING SO
LARGELY BY CLAIMING EXCEPTIONS
TO THE JUDGE'S ORDER THE MOST
COMMON ONE WAS TO CLAIM THAT A
PARENT'S CRIMINAL RECORD. EVEN
IF MINOR. MEET THE PARENT A
DANGER TO THE CHILD OR MADE IT
IMPOSSIBLE TO KEEP THE FAMILY
WITH OTHER FAMILIES IN
DETENTION. THESE SEPARATIONS.
TOTAL ELEVEN HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE CHILDREN. ONE FINAL AND
WHOLLY SEPARATE- NUMBER THAT I
KNOW WILL BE OF INTEREST OF
COMMITTEES- AT LEAST TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX PARENTS
OF SEPARATED CHILDREN ARE
BELIEVED TO BE IN. CALIFORNIA.
OUR MOVE TO CURRENT EFFORTS.
THIS FALL WE REPORTED THAT
HUNDREDS OF THE OLDEST
SEPARATIONS I THOUGHT THAT THE
FAMILIES HAS NOT BEEN LOCATED
YET. THE KEY REASONS SO MANY
FAMILIES HAVE NOT BEEN REACHED
YET IS BECAUSE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION FAILED TO
DISCLOSE INFORMATION THAT COULD
HAVE HELPED US. FIND THESE
FAMILIES. WHEN WE DID RECEIVE
INFORMATION IN TWENTY NINETEEN
ABOUT THE SEPARATIONS SOME OF
THE CHILDREN IN THIS COUNTRY
AND WITHOUT THEIR PARENTS FOR
NEARLY TWO YEARS. MAKING THINGS
WORSE THE CONTACT INFORMATION
FOR THE FAMILIES WE CAN WE WILL
STILL TO PAY OR NONEXISTENT.
I'M GOING TO PAUSE FOR A MOMENT
TO DRINK WATER. SO WHILE WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO FIND MOST
FAMILIES EVEN WITH THE LIMITED
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE- AS OF
THIS AFTERNOON- THE NUMBER IS
THE PARENTS OF SIX HUNDRED
CHILDREN HAVE YET TO BE
LOCATED- AND OF THOSE SIX
HUNDRED ABOUT ROUGHLY FOUR
HUNDRED OF THEM ARE OUTSIDE THE
UNITED STATES. WE ARE WORKING
HARD TO REACH THESE PARENTS
HOPE TO MAKE CONSIDERABLE
PROGRESS IN THE COMING MONTHS
NOW THAT. YET AGAIN- THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAD RECENTLY AND
BELATEDLY DISCLOSED ADDITIONAL
CONTACT INFORMATION FIRST. I
WANT TO QUICKLY MENTION THE KEY
ASKS WE HAVE MADE TO THE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION- OF WHICH WE
HOPE THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WILL TAKE UP AS WELL
IN THEIR ADVOCACY TO FEDERAL
OFFICIALS. FIRST IS TO REUNITE
ALL FAMILIES IN THE UNITED
STATES AND ENSURE THEY LIVE
HERE TOGETHER THREE FROM
DETENTION. THE BINDING
MINISTRATION HAS THE POWER TO
ROLL THESE FAMILIES INTO THE
COUNTRY. ALLOWING THEM TO
REUNITE AND SAFETY HERE. SECOND
DISTRICT TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
PROTECTIONS FROM DEPORTATION
FOR FAMILIES ALREADY HERE OR
FOR THOSE THAT ARE BROUGHT HERE
TO UNITE. AND THEN TO SUPPORT A
PATH TO CITIZENSHIP FOR ALL
SEPARATED FAMILIES. THERE IS A
FUND TO PROVIDE BASIC
NECESSITIES INCLUDING TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE. FOR IT IS
SYSTEMIC CHANGES TO ENSURE AN
ENDS TO FAMILY SEPARATIONS FOR.
TO CLOSE I WANT TO BE SURE NOT
TO LOSE SIGHT OF THE INDIVIDUAL
TRAGEDIES OF FAMILY SEPARATION-
I KNOW YOU ALL HAVE PAID
ATTENTION TO THE STORIES AND I
HOPE YOU WILL REMEMBER THEM-
SUCH AS ONE OF THE FIRST
REUNITED FAMILIES IN OUR CASE.
HIS MOTHER TOLD US THAT HER
FOUR YEAR OLD SON KEPT ASKING
IF THEY WERE GOING TO TAKE HIM
AWAY AGAIN. FOR THE PARENTS TO
THEIR CHILDREN WOULD BE TAKEN.
AND ASKED GOVERNMENT AGENTS FOR
A MOMENT TO GRACE THE CHILD FOR
WHAT WAS ABOUT TO BE. TO HAPPEN.
ONLY TO BE TOLD NO. OR THE
MOTHER WHO WAS FORCED TO WATCH
AS OFFICERS DROVE AWAY WITH HER
EIGHTEEN MONTH OLD. WELL MAYBE
TRY TO GET ONE LAST GLIMPSE OF
HER. IT IS THESE ACCOUNTS THAT
SHOULD MOTIVATE US TO DO RIGHT
BY THESE FAMILIES- AND ALSO FOR
QUESTIONS AND- ONCE AGAIN
THANKS FOR HAVING ME AND HAVING
SOMEONE FROM THE ACLU. CARE
THANK YOU MISTER GLENDALE- OUR
NEXT. PRESENTER IS ILEANA CAMEL
WITH A BRANCH CHIEF IMMIGRATION
INTEGRATION BRANCH. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ELIANA CAME ONCE AND
I AM IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION
BROWN CHIEF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES ALSO
KNOWN AS TFS. THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION TO TESTIFY TODAY
ABOUT THIS VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC
OF HOW TO SUPPORT IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES. HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
SHARE WITH YOU INFORMATION ON
THE TERMINOLOGY WE USE IN
CALIFORNIA TO DESCRIBE THE
SIMMERING YEAR. WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CARE AND
CUSTODY OF THE CHILDREN AND AN
OVERVIEW OF THE NEW PROGRAM
WE'RE LAUNCHING AT CSS RIGHT
POST PLACEMENT REUNIFICATION.
FOR SOME OF THESE CHILDREN. LET
ME START WITH THAT. IN
CALIFORNIA WE USE THE TERM
UNACCOMPANIED UNDOCUMENTED
MINORS FOR YOU YOU. TO DESCRIBE
THE CHILDREN WE WILL BE
DISCUSSING TODAY. THE TERM WE
USE IN CALIFORNIA IS
INTERCHANGEABLE WITH THE TERM
UNACCOMPANIED ALIEN CHILDREN.
SEE IS USED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THIS TERM IS USED
TO DESCRIBE CHILDREN WHO ARE A
UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN. B.
WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED MEANING
THERE IN THE UNITED STATES
WITHOUT LAWFUL IMMIGRATION
STATUS. AND SEE WHO EITHER HAVE
NO PARENT OR LEGAL GUARDIAN IN
THE UNITED STATES. OR NO PARENT
OR LEGAL GUARDIAN AVAILABLE. TO
PROVIDE CARE AND PHYSICAL
CUSTODY. STRUGGLING THE YOU YOU
POPULAR HAS BEEN COMPRISED OF
CHILDREN WHO CROSS THE BORDER
INTO THE UNITED STATES WITHOUT
A PARENT OR LEGAL GUARDIAN.
BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN SEVERAL THOUSAND
UNACCOMPANIED UNDOCUMENTED
MINORS CROSS BORDER EACH YEAR.
MANY FLEEING GANG VIOLENCE
NATURAL DISASTERS IN CENTRAL
AMERICA. HOWEVER AFTER THE
FEDERAL ZERO TOLERANCE POLICY
WAS IMPLEMENTED IN 200-017-2000
EIGHTEEN THE USAGE OF THE TERM
UNACCOMPANIED UNDOCUMENTED
MINORS EXPANDED TO INCLUDE
CHILDREN SEPARATED FROM THEIR
PARENTS AT THE BORDER. WERE
THERE AFTER LEFT WITHOUT A
PARENT OR LEGAL GUARDIAN. SINCE
THEIR PARENTS WERE DETAINED IN
SEPARATE ADULT FACILITIES
AWAITING AND SOME CASES
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION FOR
ENTERING THE COUNTRY WITHOUT
AUTHORIZATION AND EVENTUAL
DEPORTATION THESE CHILDREN FELL
INTO THE SECOND CATEGORY OF
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN THOSE
WITHOUT A PARENT OR LEGAL
GUARDIAN AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE
CARE. PHYSICAL CUSTODY. ALL
UNDOCUMENTED MINORS DETAINED BY
THE U. S. CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION INCLUDING THOSE
RENDERED UNACCOMPANIED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RECENT ZERO
TOLERANCE POLICY. ARE REQUIRED
BY FEDERAL LAW. IN SEVENTY TWO
HOURS TO THE CARRYING CAPACITY
OF THE US OFFICE OF REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT NO S. O. R. R. THE
COMPANY LEN CHILDREN PROGRAM IS
MANAGED BY- O. R. R. WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES AND OPERATIONAL
DIVISION OF THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. ACCORDING TO OUR
WEBSITE AS SOON AS CHILDREN AND
TRIP- OUR OUR CARE THEY ARE PUT
IN CONTACT WITH PARENTS
GUARDIANS OR RELATIVES AND THE
PROCESS OF FINDING A SUITABLE
SPONSOR IN THE UNITED STATES
BEGAN. MOST SPONSORS ARE
PARENTS OR A CLOSE FAMILY
RELATIVES LIVING IN THE UNITED
STATES. WHILE OUR OUR PROGRAMS
ARE LOOKING FOR SPONSORS
CHILDREN ARE PROVIDED AGE
APPROPRIATE PART. ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE PROVIDED AGE APPROPRIATE
CARE AND WRAPAROUND SERVICES
AND ONE OF THE APPROXIMATELY
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FACILITIES. PROGRAMS IN TWENTY
THREE STATES FUNDED BY O. R. R.
ONE THE CUTS HERE ARE THE
FEDERAL UAC PROGRAM IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CARE AND
SUPERVISION OF THESE CHILDREN
INCLUDING THE PROVISION OF
HEALTHCARE EDUCATION AND LEGAL
SERVICES. REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THE FACILITY THEY ARE HOUSED IN
IS LOCATED. IF O. R. R. FIND
SUITABLE SPONSOR IN THE
COMMUNITY THE CARE AND CUSTODY
OF THE CHILD IS TRANSFERRED TO
THAT SPONSOR. ALONG WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR PARENTS A
PROVISION. OR R. O. R. R. ALSO
DOES NOT DIRECTLY SHARING.
QUALITIES ARE ARE ALSO DOES NOT
DIRECT YOUR INFORMATION WITH
CDSS REGARDING THE PLACEMENT OF
YOU YOU I'M TO SPONSORS IN
CALIFORNIA THE U. S. DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
DOES PUBLISH AGGREGATE MONTHLY
DATA ON YOU YOU MS RELEASED TO
SPONSORS BY COUNTY AND STATE.
BECAUSE THERE IS NO FEDERAL
REQUIREMENT OR POLICY IN PLACE
ENSURING THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SHARE INFORMATION WITH STATE OR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. ON THE
PLACEMENT OF YOU AND- WE OFTEN
PIECE TOGETHER INFORMATION
REGARDING THESE CHILDREN FROM
PUBLISHED FEDERAL DATA. PUBLIC
RECORD THE LITIGATION AND
INFORMATION SHARED BY TRUSTED
PARTNERS TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THEIR LOCATION. BASED ON THE
MOST RECENT DATA PUBLISHED BY
THE U. S. HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES THE TOTAL NUMBER OF US
RELEASED TO SPONSORS IN
CALIFORNIA IN FEDERAL FISCAL
YEAR TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
WITH 800-040-0407 OUT OF A
TOTAL OF 720-008-0030 SEVEN
NATIONWIDE. AND IN FEDERAL
FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
NEW U. M. S. RELEASED TO
SPONSORS IN CALIFORNIA WHICH
TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE. OUT OF A TOTAL OF.
SIXTEEN THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN NATIONWIDE. THE
BIG DOES NOT DISTINGUISH
BETWEEN YOU YOU MS FOR RIDE
WITHOUT A PARENT OR LEGAL
GUARDIAN AND THE US WERE
SEPARATED FROM THEIR PARENTS OR
LEGAL GUARDIANS UPON ARRIVAL.
YOU TO THE FEDERAL ZERO
TOLERANCE POLICY. WHEN
THOUSANDS OF U. U. M. BEGAN
BEING RELEASED TO SPONSORS IN
CALIFORNIA BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN THE STATE BEGAN
FUNDING NONPROFITS TO PROVIDE
THESE CHILDREN WITH FREE
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES. TO
HELP THEM RIGHT THE RISE THEIR
STATUS. SINCE STATE SCHOOL YEAR
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
CDSS AWARDED OVER TWENTY POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE LEGAL
SERVICES. TO OVER. THREE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE YOU AND- THANK YOU YOU
ONLY SERVICES PROGRAM HAS
FUNDED AN AVERAGE OF TWENTY
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
ANNUALLY. TO PROVIDE
REPRESENTATION FOR YOU YOU I'M
SPEAKING IMMIGRATION REMEDIES
INCLUDING ASYLUM SPECIAL
IMMIGRANT JUVENILE STATUS YOU
YOU M. PIECES AND TV SETS. THIS
IS YOUR CSS IS ALSO BEGAN
ADMINISTERING A NEW PROJECT
PROVIDES PLACEMENT FAMILY
REUNIFICATION SERVICES TO U. M.
AND THEIR SPONSORS. CALL THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOUTH PROJECT
OR- FY. GOAL OF THE PROJECT IS
TO IDENTIFY BEST PRACTICES TO
SUPPORT THE REUNIFICATION OF
THESE YOUTH AND THEIR FAMILIES.
TO IMPLEMENT THIS PROJECT CDSS
IS USING FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
APPROPRIATED THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. FIND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AND THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO PROVIDE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES TO THESE
YOUTH AND THEIR FAMILIES. THE
OPRAH WHY SERVICES PROVIDERS
WILL BE SERVING YOU AND THEIR
FAMILIES IN THE CENTRAL COAST
CENTRAL VALLEY LOS ANGELES.
INLAND EMPIRE AND SAN FRANCISCO
BAY REGION. THE- ACQUIRE
PROJECT COMPONENTS INCLUDE CASE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM NAVIGATION
YOUTH MENTORING AND COACHING
AND FAMILY SUPPORT WORKSHOPS.
CDSS ALSO CONDUCTING A MIXED
METHODS EVALUATION AND
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO INCREASE CAPACITY AMONG
SERVICE PROVIDERS. WELL ALL THE
PARTICIPATING PARTICIPATING
SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE ALREADY
WORKING WITH UNANIMOUS AT THEIR
NONPROFIT LEGAL SERVICE
PROVIDER OR AT THEIR SCHOOLS
THE EXPECT THAT THEY WILL BE
RECRUITING YOUTH AND FAMILY
SPECIFICALLY PROPOSED PLACEMENT
FAMILY REUNIFICATION SERVICES.
UNDER THE- WHY PROJECTS
STARTING NEXT MONTH. BOTH WIFI
EVEREST IS FOR YOU THEN THERE-
ARE EXPECTED TO BEGIN IN
FEBRUARY OR MARCH DEPENDING ON
THE PROVIDER OF THIS YEAR AND
RUN THROUGH DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST. THIRTY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SHARING BEST
PRACTICES FROM THIS PROJECT AND
CONTINUED TO FIND WAYS TO
SUPPORT UNACCOMPANIED
UNDOCUMENTED MINORS AND THEIR
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY CHAU
CORPORATION YOU TODAY. THANK
YOU MISS THANK YOU MISS CAMEL
WITH- OUR NEXT PRESENTER IS
JEAN CHEN PROGRAM ADMINISTRATOR
STATEWIDE CHILDREN'S
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAM. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JEAN
CHEN AND I'M THE PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATOR FOR OUR
CHILDREN'S RESIDENTIAL PROGRAM
WITHIN CDSS COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING DIVISION. I HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO SPEAK AT VALUE HAVE
CHILDREN WHO ARE CARE FOR IN
OUR LICENSE CAN YOU HEAR. WELL
OUR PRICES LOW CASE EQUAL
SPONSOR OR IF THEY ARE UNABLE
TO FIND ONE. YOU M. CHILDREN
MAYBE PLACE IN STATE LICENSE
CHILVERS RESIDENTIAL FRAMING
AND CONTRACT WITH- ARE. EITHER
THE SAME CDSS LICENSE SETTING
HOMES OR EFFORT FACED AGENCIES
SUPERVISE HOMES USED FOR FOSTER
YOUTH SPECIAL EDUCATION
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES AND
VOLUNTARY PRIVATE PLACEMENT-
OUR OUR CONTRACTS DIRECTLY WITH
SOME OF THESE FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA FOR SHELTER A STRICT
HERE AS BANISHMENT EDUCATION
AND MEDICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. TO THESE MINES CDSS
IS NOT INFORMED WHEN THESE
CONTRACTS ARE SIGNED AND DOES
NOT HAVE COPIES OF. CDSS
THEREFORE DOES NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO INFORMATION ABOUT THESE
MINERS EXCEPT THE RIVER OR
DEALT AND THAT'S OBTAINED
DURING A LICENSING INSPECTION
OR INVESTIGATION. THESE
FACILITIES SERVE ALL OUR
PLACEMENT EXCLUSIVELY OR ALONG
WITH OTHER POPULATIONS. HOWEVER
YOU YOU AND LIVING IN FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY HOME OR GROUP%
HOMES ARE NOT MIXED WITH OTHER
TYPES OF A- THESE FACILITIES
MAY HAVE EXISTED BEFORE
SERVING- OUR BASEMENTS OR AYE
FOR LICENSED HERE TO SERVE ALL
OUR- CAN MEET YOUR LICENSING
DIVISION. THAT'S THE DSS IS THE
CALIFORNIA LICENSING ENTITY OR
CHILDREN'S RESIDENTIAL SETTING
AS MENTIONED THE TWO TYPES OF
LICENSED FACILITIES UTILIZED BY
OUR OUR REPLACEMENT. ARE ALSO
FAMILY AGENCY AND GROUP.
HERMITE THERE ARE SIX FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY PROVIDERS WITH
TWELVE OFFICE LOCATIONS THAT
HAVE HOMES CARING YOU IN. AND
WE HAVE EIGHT GROUP HOME
PROVIDER SERVING SEVENTEEN
GROUP HOMES LIKE. THESE LICENSE
CATEGORIES ARE NOT EXCLUSIVELY
OR OUR PLACEMENTS THEY ARE ALSO
USED FOR FOSTER YOUTH SPECIAL
EDUCATION CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES INVOLVED. THANK I
REQUEST CTLT ENSURES THAT EACH
LICENSE FACILITY MEETS THE
STATE'S HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
STAFFING REQUIREMENTS THESE
LAWS CAN BE FOUND GETTING
PROTECTION FIFTEEN HUNDRED OF
CHAPTER THREE DIVISION TWO OF
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE AND THE REGULATIONS
CAN BE FOUND IN TITLE TWENTY
TWO DIVISIONS. SIX OF THE
CALIFORNIA CODE OF REGULATIONS-
ARE ARE DOES NOT CONSULT WITH
THE C. L. Y. SE CDSS WE CARE
LICENSING WHEN SEEKING CAPACITY
FOR PLACE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
MISS TEN OUR NEXT PRESENTER IS
pRYAN MATLOW CLINICAL ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR DEPARTMENT OF
PSYCHIATRY AND BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'D LIKE TO START BY
THINKING THIS JOIN ASSEMBLY FOR
ATENDING TO THE RECEPTION CARE
DIMINISH OTHER THAN THE UNITED
STATES IN CALIFORNIA. GIVE ME
AN OPPORTUNITY SHARE MY
EXPERIENCES AND OBSERVATIONS
THE PSYCHOLOGICAL BEING. OF
THIS COMMUNITY. SO I WAS
OUTSIDE COLLEGES MY WORK
FOCUSES ON ADDRESSING AND
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPACT OF
TELECOM ADVERSITY I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH IMMIGRANT YOUTH
AND FAMILIES PRIMARILY FROM
CENTRAL AMERICAN COUNTRIES FOR
ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS. CONDUCTING
TRAUMA FOCUSED CLINICAL
ASSESSMENT AND THERAPEUTIC
INTERVENTION. IN PARTICULAR. IN
THE LAST FOUR YEARS I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE MONITORING AND
EVALUATION OF THE SPECIFIC
IMPACT US GOVERNMENT POLICY AND
PRACTICE OF PSYCHOLOGICAL WELL
BEING OF CHILDREN FAMILIES
SEEKING REFUGE INCLUDING THOSE
IMPACTED BY IT ZERO TOLERANCE
BY THE PROLIFERATION OF CHILD
DETENTION. MY REMAIN MEXICO
POLICIES BY CURRENT ASYLUM.
THIS WORK IS INVOLVED VISITS TO
CUSTODY SETTINGS IN DIRECT
CONVERSATIONS WITH CHILDREN
WHILE THEY'RE DETAINED IN THE
MIDST OF ONGOING SEPARATION
FROM THE CHARACTERS. AS WELL AS
WORK WITH FAMILIES NAVIGATING.
A CHALLENGING PROCESS TO REMOVE
OF REUNIFICATION FOLLOWING
GOVERNMENT PLUS SEPARATION.
I'VE BEEN HONORED AND GRATEFUL
TO BE PRESENT WITH THESE
FAMILIES AS THEY SHARE THEIR
EXPERIENCES AND STRUGGLES MANY
OF WHOM WONDER STORIES TO BE
TOLD. WITH THIS WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO LISTEN. IN
THIS WORK I'VE BEEN BOTH STRUCK
AN INCREDIBLE RESILIENCE SHOWN
BY KIDS AND FAMILIES IS IT
PERSEVERED THROUGH MULTIPLE
ADVERSITIES AND TRAUMAS. THE
RAIN FROM TARGETED VIOLENCE
EXPOSURE IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
OF ORIGIN. GEN TO THE THREAT
RISK AN ADDITIONAL BALLOTS
EXPOSURE EXPERIENCED DURING THE
MIGRATION JOURNEY. TO THE
UNANTICIPATED TRAUMAS
EXPERIENCED AT THE HANDS OF US
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS UPON
ARRIVAL. THROUGH THIS CHILDREN
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS I REMAIN
HOPEFUL FOR FUTURE OF SAFETY
AND SECURITY. AND COMMITTED TO
THEIR FMILIES WELL BEING AND
THEY REMAIN OPEN TO BOTH
RECEIVING AND GIVING SUPPORT.
AND TO BUILDING COMMUNITY
DURING THE TIME OF CRITICAL
NEED IN CRISIS. THIS IS THE
MOST IMPRESSIVE. HOWEVER THE
IMPACTS OF US POLICY IN
PRACTICE PARTICULARLY
SEPARATION UNDERMINES
RESILIENCE IT IS IN DIRECT
VIOLATION OF AIMS TO PURSUE THE
BEST INTERESTS OF CHILDREN.
FIRST MOMENTS OF THE FOURTH
FAMILY SEPARATION ARE MARKED BY
ACUTE AND SEVERE DISTRESS
INCLUDING INCLUDING PANIC
CONFUSION AND DISEMPOWER. SH
CAN BARELY MEMBERS ARE GIVEN
INFORMATION ON THE RATIONALE
NATURE AND COURSES OF
SEPARATION IN THE FREQUENTLY
BEEN MISLED- WORST AND
SOMETIMES PHYSICALLY TORN ONE
ANOTHER'S ARMS BY IMMIGRATION
AGENTS. AS EXPERIENCES BECOME
IMPRINTED IN THEIR MEMORIES AND
PSYCHOLOGY. DENNIS EXPERIENCE
EXPERIENCE IN THIS CONTEXT IS
PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE TRAUMA IS
SUBJECT. WHAT MAKES A CHALLENGE
OR POTENTIAL THREAT DRAMATIC IS
NOT KNOWING WHAT IS HAPPENING
AND NOT FEELING A SENSE OF
AGENCY TO AFFECT THE OUTCOME.
AND THIS RESULTS IN EXTREME
FEAR ANXIETY AND DYSREGULATION
BOOKS FOR CHILDREN AND THEIR
CAREGIVERS. THAT BECOME SUSTAIN
DROP PROCESSING IN CUSTODY IN A
SYSTEM THAT IS UNFAMILIAR AND
OFTEN THREATEN. WITH KIDS AND
CAREGIVERS A DIFFICULTY IN
ACCESSING TRADITIONAL SUPPORTS.
OVERTIMES INCITING PANIC BECOME
ACCOMPANIED BY SANDERS DESPAIR
AND HOPELESSNESS. SPOKEN WITH
TEENAGERS IN CUSTODY INSTEAD
THEY'RE SPENDING EVERY DAY ONE
ABOUT THE CARE GIVERS
WHEREABOUTS AND WHERE WE AND
WELL BEING. THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
FOCUS ON ANYTHING ELSE AND
EVERY DAY THEY BREAK DOWN IN
TEARS BECAUSE THERE HELP ME
FEEL HELPLESS TO DO ANYTHING.
THIS IS NO WAY FOR A CHILD TO
BE SPENDING CRITICAL FORMATIVE
DEVELOPMENTAL YEARS. AS THESE
REACTIONS TO THE TRAUMA OF
SEPARATION BECOMING GREAT.
INDEED DECADES OF RESEARCH ON
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES A TOXIC
STRESS. AND SHOWN THE
EXPERIENCES OF SEVERE BELONGS
RIGHT IN THE ABSENCE OF
PROTECTIVE CARE GIVING SUPPORTS
IN SESSIONS LASTING
PSYCHOLOGICAL HARM. WITH
LITERAL ALTERATIONS IN BRAIN
STRUCTURE AND FUNCTION. AS WELL
AS IMPAIRMENT BIOLOGICAL
FUNCTIONING THE IMPACT LONG
TERM HEALTH AND PERFORMANCE
OUTCOMES. JONES LEFT
UNADRESSED WE CAN EXPECT THESE
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN IMPACTED
BY SEPARATION PRACTICES. HE
WHAT PART OF CHILDREN'S
RESILIENCE IS THAT THE ADAPTING
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT THEY ARE AT
BUT ADAPTATIONS THE HARMFUL
CIRCUMSTANCES PROPELLED
AMERICAN OTHER CONTEXTS AND
ALTERATIONS IN A CHILD'S
DEVELOPMENT TRAJECTORY THAT ARE
BASED ON EXTREME AND CHRONIC
THREAT OF SEVERE CONSEQUENCES.
IN HUMANE SOCIETY IT IS IN
NOBODY'S BEST INTEREST PER
CHILD TO EXPERIENCE PERSISTENT
AUTOMATIC THOUGHTS AND FEELINGS
THAT I AM IN DANGER. THERE'S
NOBODY NOBODY TO PROTECT ME AND
THERE'S NOTHING I CAN DO TO
HELP MYSELF OR MY LOVED ONES.
THESE PATTERNS OF TRAUMA
RELATED COGNITION AND AFFECT IN
THE SOCIAL BEHAVIORS CLEARLY
IMPACT ENGAGEMENT IN SCHOOLS
AND HEALTH CARE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. IN IN THE DISTRESS
OF SEPARATION WE SEE
SIGNIFICANT DISRUPTIONS IN
PARENT CHILD ATTACHMENT WHICH
IS THE PHYSIOLOGICAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL CONNECTION
BETWEEN CHILDREN AND THEIR
CAREGIVERS. THAT IS
FOUNDATIONAL FOR HEALTHY CHILD
ABOUT. FOR SEPARATION BREAKS
THE BONDS OF TRUST AND SECURITY
IN A RELATIONSHIP. AND EVEN
WELL AFTER REUNIFICATION
THERE'S LASTING DISTRESS AND
PARENT CHILD RELATIONSHIPS AND
FAMILY FUNCTION. WHAT WE IN
TRYING TO MAKE SENSE OF THE
CONFUSION OF SEPARATION
CHILDREN MAY COME TO BLAME
THEMSELVES OR THEIR CAREGIVERS
AND OUTCOMES OF IMPOSED BY
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS. THIS CAN
LEAD TO LASTING SHAME ANGER
RESENTMENT AND FAMILY CONFLICT.
IT CAN TAKE YEARS OF
THERAPEUTIC WORK TO RESTORE A
SENSE OF SAFETY AND STABILITY
AND CONSISTENCY IN THE PARENT
CHILD ATTACHMENT. AND IMPACT IS
COOLEY BIDIRECTIONAL AFFECTING
PARENTS AS WELL. IN ADDITION TO
THE LASTING TRAUMA SPENDING FOR
A LONG TIME NOT KNOWING IF YOUR
CHILD IS OKAY BEING RENDERED
HELPLESS TO PROTECT THEM FROM
HARM. THE PROCESS OF
REUNIFICATION IS OFF THE MARK
RICHARD OR STRUGGLING TO
UNDERSTAND AND TO RECOGNIZE THE
CHILD. STRUGGLING TO JIM
JOHNSON AND BEHAVIOR STEMMING
FROM THE SEPARATION. AND
STRUGGLING WITH THEIR OWN
FEELINGS OF SHAME AND GUILT
THAT AFFECTS RENTAL
EFFECTIVENESS. AND WHILE THE
HARMS MAYBE DIRE THERE REMAIN
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STABILIZATION
RECOVERY GROWTH AND HEALING
THAT CAPITALIZE ON THE
RESILIENCE AND PERSEVERANCE
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN FAMILIES.
THESE OUTCOMES ARE NOT YET
DETERMINED. JUST TO NAME A
COUPLE EXAMPLES OF PROCESS OF
RECOVERY STARTED HEARING
CAPTURING ANY KNOWLEDGE IN
FAMILIES EXPERIENCES. AND
IMPACTS OF THESE INTENTIONAL
STRATEGIES TO DETER THE PURSUIT
OF SAFETY SECURITY AND HEALTH.
AND BY GIVING CHILDREN FAMILIES
AGENCY IN PARTICULAR THEIR
NEEDS AND TO INFORM OUR
RESPONSE. WE ALSO HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO PURSUE POLICY
TO PREVENT A REPETITION OF
THESE HARMS. IN MOST PRACTICAL
IMPORTANTLY TO HELP RESOURCES
AND SYSTEMS OF CARE THE
COMPREHENSIVELY ADDRESSED NEEDS
LASTING AND COMPLEX NEEDS OF
CHILDREN FAMILIES AFFECTED BY
SEPARATION PRACTICES. SO I
HEARD OUR STATE AND OUR
POLICYMAKERS THROUGH GAUGING
EFFORTS TOWARDS THESE ENDS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
DOCTOR ABOUT LOW. I THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY I WOULD
NOW LIKE TO OPEN IT UP TO YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS- IF ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I HAVE A QUESTION
PLEASE RAISE YOUR MICROPHONE.
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT- THE STATISTICS
THERE WERE PROVIDED I DO THIS
IS FOR ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE PANEL. YES THE STATISTICS
GIVEN I KNOW HER VERY WELL I'D
LIKE TO KNOW HOW MANY CHILDREN
STILL ARE SEPARATED FROM THEIR
PARENTS HAVE NOT BEEN REUNITED
WITH THEIR PARENTS. THAT ANYONE
ON THE PANEL CAN ANSWER MISTER
GLENDORA THINK HAVE PROVIDED.
YEAH I CAN I CAN BE I CAN BEGIN
TO ANSWER THAT THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION. THE. THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE FOR THE QUESTION IS
ESSENTIALLY THAT THERE IS A
LARGE GROUP OF CHILDREN THE SIX
HUNDRED PERRANCE- PARENTS OF
CHILDREN SEPARATED BUT WE
HAVEN'T REACHED THE PARENT SO
IN THAT SENSE WE DON'T KNOW.
THE STATUS OF THE FAMILY SO
THAT SO ESSENTIALLY THERE IS
SUCH A LARGE GROUP. OR HOME NOT
SURE WHAT THEIR STATUS IS IN
WITHOUT REACHING THE PARENT WHO
CAN'T FIGURE THAT OUT. THAT IT
MAKES ANY SORT OF PRECISE
NUMBER- QUITE QUITE DIFFICULT
UNFORTUNATELY SO. WE HOPE TO
GET. ESPECIALLY GIVEN JUST THE-
OVER ARCHING THE SUCH A LARGE
NUMBER OF SEPARATION. WE HOPE
TO BE ABLE TO. PROVIDE THAT
KIND OF CLARITY AND I KIND OF
NUMBER WHILE THERE IS STILL A
LARGE POOL OF CHILDREN- FOR
WHOM WE HAVEN'T REACHED THEIR
FAMILIES IT IT BECOMES VERY
DIFFICULT. TO DO SO. AND AS A
FOLLOW PERFORMING THAT MEASURE.
JEFF IS AN ARTICLE THAT CAME
OUT TODAY- THE VICE
ADMINISTRATION HAS COMMITTED TO
WORKING TO REUNITE THE CHILDREN
WITH THEIR PARENTS DOES THIS
GIVE YOU MORE HOPE DONE AND
FINDING THESE PARENTS AND
GETTING THEM TOGETHER WITH
THEIR CHILDREN. YES ABSOLUTELY
IT IT- YOU KNOW IT IT IT HAS
BEEN. DISCUSSED FOR QUITE SOME
TIME AND BEEN PART OF- NO- NOW
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S- CAMPAIGN WAS
TO PLEDGE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS AND TO TAKE CONCRETE STEPS
SO- YOU KNOW. IN VERY TANGIBLE
FORM- WE HAVE CONSISTENTLY HAD
DIFFICULTY GETTING- UPDATED
INFORMATION AND UPDATED CONTACT
INFORMATION FOR FAMILIES FROM
THE GOVERNMENT AND SO- PLEDGE
TO HELP TO DO SO IN TWO. ENGAGE
IN THAT PROCESS AND- COOPERATE
WITH IT AND TRY TO MOVE IT
FORWARD IS A VERY VERY WELCOME
CHANGE. THANK YOU MISTER
GLENDALE DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS MISTER MISTER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RUN CHAIR
MISTER GLENDALE I HAVE A
QUESTION A FOLLOW UP ON-
REGARDING THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN SEPARATED I UNDERSTAND
FROM A NEW YORK- THE NEW YORK
TIMES IS ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE- CHILDREN. AND THIS
WAS BASED ON I GUESS KNOCKED
OVER TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY I
GUESS MY REAL QUESTION IS THERE
THAT NUMBER REPRESENTS- THE
CHILDREN WHO ARE STILL
OUTSTANDING WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
REUNITED WITH THEIR- PARENTS-
AND THEN WHAT METHOD ARE YOU
USING. TO TRY TO REACH THE
COMMUNITIES THAT MAY KNOW
SOMETHING TO TRY TO REACH THOSE
AND REUNITE THOSE CHILDREN WITH
THOSE PARENTS IS THEIR
COMMUNICATION IS GOING OUT OF
SPANISH WHAT ARE THE BOOTS ON
THE GROUND TO TRY TO REALLY-
YOU KNOW I'M FRIDAY MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE. THOSE MOTHERS AND
FATHERS NO IF YOUR CHILDREN ARE
THERE SO WHAT KIND OF
COMMUNICATIONS ARE IN FACT
BEING USED TO TRY TO REACH OF
THE PARENTS BECAUSE THE KIDS
THE KIDS CAME WITH THE PARENTS
THAT HAVE. TO BE THE PARENTS
REACHING THE KIDS. YES SO I
WILL I'LL TAKE THAT QUESTION-
IN. IN EACH PART- SO IN OCTOBER
THE FIVE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
NUMBER REFERS TO. THE OLDEST
SEPARATIONS- ONLY AND THAT WAS
THE NUMBER OF PARENTS THAT WE
HAVE NOT REACHED AT THAT POINT-
THE REASON WE USE SIX HUNDRED
NOW IS BECAUSE THERE IS A SMALL
GROUP. OF PARENTS WHO WERE
DISCLOSED TO US LATE BUT ARE
NOT AMONG THE OLDEST
SEPARATIONS AND THAT IS A GROUP
WHERE WE- ESSENTIALLY THERE IS
NO REASON TO MAKE A DISTINCTION
BETWEEN. WHEN A FAMILY WAS
DISCLOSED PURPOSE OF WHETHER OR
NOT WE NEED TO FIND THEM SO-
YOU KNOW AND AS WE TRY TO
IMPROVE THE WAY REPORT OUT
NUMBERS WE HAVE TRIED TO
BASICALLY. TREATED AS THE MOST
ACCURATE NUMBER THAT WE CAN
GIVE TAT INCLUDES ALL CHILDREN
ACROSS ANY POINT AT WHICH THEY
WERE DISCLOSED TO US. HAVE WE
FOUND THEIR PARENTS ARE NOT SO.
THE FIVE FORTY FIVE IS INCLUDED
WITHIN THE SIX HUNDRED NUMBER I
CITED TO YOU. AND MOST
IMPORTANT THERE IS. WE JUST
DON'T KNOW UNTIL WE REACH THAT
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE STATUS
THAT FAMILY IS AND WE HAVE TO-
TRY TO GUARD AGAINST THE WORST
POSSIBLE OUTCOME WHICH WOULD BE
THAT THEY ARE STILL SEPARATED-
WORRIED AND POSSIBLY EVEN NOT
IN CONTACT WHICH WOULD BE THE
SORT OF NIGHTMARE SCENARIO. SO
THAT'S WHAT MOTIVATES THE
SEARCHES. I ON THE SECOND PART
OF THE QUESTION I'LL TRY TO BE
BRIEF- YES THERE ARE EFFORTS ON
THE GROUND IN COMMUNITIES- IN
CENTRAL AMERICA. PRIMARILY IN
GUATEMALA WE'RE THE LARGEST SET
OF. SEPARATED FAMILIES IS FROM-
SO WE PARTNER WITH A GROUP
CALLED JUSTICE IN MOTION THAT
WORKS WITH A NETWORK OF-
FREQUENTLY THERE EITHER HUMAN
RIGHTS LAWYERS IN THEIR HOME
COUNTRIES WHO WORKS TO. TRACK
FOLKS DOWN- AND THAT. AS AS I
THINK YOUR QUESTION RIGHTLY
ANTICIPATES- SOMEONE GIVES AND
IT. IS A PAINSTAKING PROCESS-
IT IS PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT IN
A PANDEMIC AND HAS BEEN FROZEN
AT DIFFERENT POINTS DEPENDING
ON- LOCAL HEALTH CONDITIONS.
AND IT IS ALSO EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT GIVEN THE HURRICANES
THAT PASSED THROUGH THOSE
COUNTRIES AT THIS TIME SO I
THINK THAT THAT BEGINS TO
EXPLAIN SOME OF JUST THE- SHEER
DIFFICULTIES BUT- IT DOES
LITERALLY INVOLVED GOING TO
COMMUNITIES. SPEAKING TO ELDERS
AND COMMUNITIES USING WHATEVER
SNIPPETS OF INFORMATION. ARE
AVAILABLE LOOKING AT BIRTH
REGISTRIES- AND SO ON AND SO ON
AND THAT HAS YIELDED. RESULTS
IT IS. LED TO DOZENS AND DOZENS
OF FAMILIES FOUND BUT IT IS
UNDERSTANDABLY QUITE SLOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. TO HAVE
ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS HELLO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AMBULANCE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF MY
QUESTION TODAY IS GOING TO BE
FOR DR MATHEW LOW IF I CAN. ON
PAGE FIVE OF OUR BACKGROUND
PAPERS TODAY IT STATES THAT
CHILDREN WHO ARE SEPARATED FROM
THEIR FAMILIES AT THE BORDER
NOT ONLY FACE TRAUMA CAUSED BY
DISRUPTIONS IN THEIR
ATTACHMENT. TO CARING ADULTS
BUT THEY ARE ALSO PROCESSING
THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT LED THEM
TO SEEK ASYLUM IN THE FIRST
PLACE SUCH AS WAR AND VIOLENCE
IN THEIR HOME COUNTRIES. I WAS
IMPRESSED BY WHAT YOU SAID. AND
REALLY WANTS TO ECHO IT IF I
CAN. YOUR STATEMENTS FOR THAT
THIS CAN LEAD TO LASTING
PSYCHOLOGICAL HARM. BUT THAT
THESE OUTCOMES ARE NOT YET
DETERMINED. THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
IMPRESSED BY THE RESILIENCY AND
THE KIDS THAT YOU'VE SEEN. MY
QUESTION FOR YOU TODAY DR MATT
LAUER. IS THE EARLY DETECTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION IS KEY
IN HELPING TO PREVENT AND
REDUCE THE HEALTH RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES OR ACES.
CAN WE PROVIDE A SCREENINGS TWO
ONE DOCUMENT A CHILDREN
SEPARATED FROM THEIR FAMILIES
TO SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE THE
HEALTH. AND WELL BEING AND
POTENTIALLY. PREVENTING THESE
CHILDREN FROM DEVELOPING MENTAL
ILLNESS SUCH AS ANXIETY
DISORDERS DEPRESSION AND
SUICIDAL IDEATIONS. YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF THE QUESTION
FOR YOUR COMMENTS ON. AN
ABSOLUTELY PART OF OUR CONCERN
IS THAT WE KNOW THE STRESS AND
TRAUMA IS CUMULATIVE SO IT'S
NOT ABOUT JUST LOOKING AT ONE
EXPERIENCE OF ADVERSITY OR
TRAUMA AND ISOLATION JUST AND
NEXT EXPERIENCE OF SEPARATION
BUT TO LOOK AT THE PRODUCTS
WHAT'S NEXT FOR THE MULTIPLE
TRAUMAS ADVERSITIES THAT
CHILDREN HAVE EXPERIENCED. WE
KNOW THAT CHILDREN FAMILIES ARE
FLEEING FROM VIOLENCE OR
NATURAL DISASTER HAS BEEN
MENTIONED RIGHT SO- WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ACCUMULATION. OF TRUNKS AND THE
SPECIFIC. THE SPECIFICALLY. OF
THE IMPACT OF SECTION WHICH
AGAIN IS NOT JUST A ONE TIME
THING BUT IT'S BEEN A LONG
PROCESS FOR MANY MANY FAMILIES-
HOW THAT INFORMS OUR EARTH X.
THE DEVELOPMENTAL TRAJECTORY.
OF CHILDREN- AND WHEN WE SAY
THAT THE OUTCOME WAS NOT TO
DETERMINE THIS BECAUSE- MANY OF
THESE CHILDREN AND EVEN INTO
ADULTHOOD THERE REMAIN
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HEALING AND
RECOVERY. AND FOR- AGAIN
ALTERING THE PATH THAT. I'M
INTRODUCTORY COURSE POSITIVE
OUTCOMES. ARE ABLE TAKING THAT
EARLY INTERVENTION IS KEY
EARLIER THAT WE CAN. CATCH AND
ADDRESS- ANY DIFFICULTIES IF
PEOPLE ARE EXPERIENCING- WHAT'S
TRIMIX BORDER CHALLENGE THE
LITTLE REGRESSIONS APPEARS KIND
OF GOING BACK TO EARLIER STAGES
OF FUNCTIONING. BUT IF WE CAN
PROVIDE SAFETY STABILITY. SKILL
BUILDING- THEN THAT. HELPED
SHAPE THE PATH TOWARDS RECOVERY
IN TOWARDS HEALING. SO AGAIN.
SO THERE ARE MANY WAYS
VULNERABLE BECAUSE THEY'RE VERY.
TO WHAT HOW THERE VIRUS MORE
SENSITIVE EVEN MORE SO I WOULD
SAY THN IN ADULTS TO TRAUMAS
AND- CITIES. AND AFFORDABILITY
IS BASED ON HOW THAT
EXPERIENCING TRAUMA ALTERS THAT
THE LITTLE TRAJECTORY AT THE
SAME TIME CHILDREN ARE VERY
OPEN AND RECEPTIVE TO. POSITIVE
INTERVENTION THE POSITIVE LIFE
EXPERIENCES TO THE DEVELOPMENT
OF NEW SKILLS THAT HELP WITH
EMOTION REGULATION OR HELP WITH
YOUR HELP IN COPING WITH.
DEPRESSION ANXIETY SYMPTOMS OF
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
AND SO THE EARLIER WE CAN
INTERVENE. EARLIER OF THE
COMPLEXITY INSTABILITY- AND-
THERE WOULD STILL YOU KNOW TRY
TO ASK BUILDING PRACTICE IN
DEALING- THE MORE. AND
OPTIMISTIC WE CAN BE ABOUT LONG
TERM SO AGAIN WE STILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO- ADDRESS THE
HARMS OF FAMILY SEPARATION. AND
AGAIN THAT THE SOONER THAT WE
MOBILIZE AND THE QUICKER WE CAN
WE CAN CATCH FAMILIES AND
IDENTIFY THE SKILLS ARE NEEDED
INTERVIEW NOT WAIT THE BETTER
OFF- YOU CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
WILL BE. ALL THINK I'LL JUST
END BY SAYING I THINK WE HAVE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT- REUNIFYING
FAMILIES THIS THE FIRST STEP.
BUT FOLLOWING UNIFICATION THERE
IS- SIGNIFICANT. DIFFICULTY AND
YOU JUST. AND THE CYCLONE HARM
DO NOT RESOLVE JUST FOR
GREENVILLE. SO WE ALSO NED TO
BE THE- ABOUT LONGER- SERVICES
AND INTERVENTIONS JUST AS YOU
SEE SUGGESTED. MY FINAL
QUESTION TODAY YOU'LL ALLOW ME
MADAM IS. YOUR ENDING COMMON
THE INITIAL WAS A DOCTOR MATT
LAUER THAT WE NEED TO DEVELOP
RESOURCE AND POLICIES THAT CAN
HELP I WAS HOPING YOU CAN
ELABORATE A LITTLE FURTHER AND-
WE MAY NEED TO DO IT OFFLINE
BUT WANT TO GIVE YOU A CHANCE
TO- SHARE MORE IF YOU COULD.
YEAH I THINK YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
HAPPY SINCE IT IS A OF. FRESH
LARGE CONVERSATIONS I WOULD
HAPPEN TO CONTINUE THAT THAT
OFFLINE I DO THINK THAT THAT'S
ALSO A PART OF THE SLAVE FROM
THE SUBSEQUENT AND ALSO I'M I'M
LOOKING TOWARDS THOSE AS WELL
AS- WILL KILL THE MORE ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING WHAT ARE SOME
OF THE OPPORTUNITIES- SH. BUT I
WILL SAY BRIEFLY THAT. YOU KNOW
WHAT I THINK THERE'S A NEED TO-
ACKNOWLEDGE THE HARMS OF THE
BEEN COMMITTED. A KNOWLEDGE THE
IMPACT AGAIN THIS IS WHERE WE
SEE HISTORIES OF. TRAUMA AND
OPPRESSION REPEATING THEMSELVES
BECAUSE- THE HISTORIES AND
NARRATIVES ARE NOT FULLY
ACKNOWLEDGE ARE NOT FULLY
COMPLETE AND SO THERE'S SOME
ROOM FIRST INITIAL PUBLIC
PUBLICLY ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF THE
IMPACT OF THESE PRACTICES- IT
ALSO IT REALLY BUILDING OUR OUR
SYSTEMS OF CARE. ON THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY GEARED AND-
SENSITIVE TO THE NEEDS AND
BACKGROUND OF CHILDREN FAMILIES
AND SO- THIS INCLUDES TRAUMA
INFORMED SERVICES TRAUMA
FOCUSED THERAPY SERVICES-
THERAPEUTIC SERVICES THAT FOCUS
ON REBUILDING THAT SENSE OF THE
ATTACHMENT CONNECTION BETWEEN
THE CHILD AND THE CAREGIVER.
AND ALSO A SPOKESMAN MENTIONED
IN THE OPENING REMARKS-
ASSEMBLY WRAPAROUND SERVICES
KNOWING THAT- THE NEEDS OF OUR
CHILDREN FAMILIES AND THEN
SEPARATED ARE COMPLEX. WELL
THAT THEY HAVE LEGAL NEEDS THEY
HOLD. HEALTH NEEDS TO HAVE MET
THEY HAVE PSYCHOLOGICAL MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS AND REALLY THE
MORE THAT WE CAN BE INTEGRATED
AND WORKING ACROSS OUR
DISCIPLINES IN COORDINATING OUR
RESPONSE- THE MORE EFFECTIVE WE
CAN BE AND SO THIS IS A
COMMUNITY FOR WHICH- THIS
INTERDISCIPLINARY- WRAPAROUND
SERVICEABILITY. IS A PARTICULAR
NEED AND- ONE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT CALIFORNIA CAN DO YOU TO
DEVOTE. RESOURCES TO THOSE
TYPES OF SYSTEMS OF CARE. THANK
YOU MATT LOW. DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBER THAT PROTEST
REMOTE THAT HAVE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY I. AM SORRY IF I JUST
MAKE A COMMENT I APPRECIATE DR
RAM VILAS LINE OF QUESTIONING
IN AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO DO IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM AND EVEN THE
LATEST MOVES. WITH THE- DIGITAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM EMBRACING AND
UNDERSTANDING. AND ON DOING THE
EFFECT OF ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES. BRING THOSE
NOTIONS INTO OUR SYSTEM OF CARE
AND YET HERE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A GOVERNMENTAL SYSTEM.
THAT IS CREATING ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES THAT WILL
BE LEFT FOR STATE AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS TO TRY AND UNDO
IN THE FUTURE THAT THAT IS WHAT
IS FOR ME ONE OF THE MOST
FRUSTRATING. ALLEN'S OF THIS IS
WHAT HAS BEEN CREATED AND YET
YOU CALIFORNIA TRYING TO MOVE
AHEAD AND BRINGING EXACTLY THAT
KIND OF THERAPEUTIC APPROACH TO
OUR SYSTEM OF CARE REALLY BEING
ON DONE BY LARGER IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM THAT'S HERE IT'S JUST
VERY FRUSTRATING AND I KNOW TAX
REVENUE THAT'S AT THE HEART OF.
AND WHERE YOUR QUESTIONS LIVE.
THANK YOU CHEST DOWN. YEAH I
CAN ASK I MEAN. CALIFORNIA
ALWAYS SEEMS THE LEAD AT ANY
CRISIS THAT WE HAVE. YOU ALWAYS
GET A LOT OF FOLKS I'M JUST NOT
TALKING DEBORAH I'M CHUCK IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR THE ALSO
JUMPS IN HERE JUST IT IT SEEMS
THAT. THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
NOT NOT IN JUST GOVERNMENT'S
GONNA ANSWER AND FIXES BUT ARE
WE GETTING FOLKS FROM THE
OUTSIDE TO GET THE PRIVATE
SECTOR TO SAY HEY YOU KNOW WHAT
I REALLY WANT TO JOIN IN AND
HELP I MEAN HAVE WE GOTTEN A
MASKING- PARTICIPANTS HAVE WE
GOTTEN A POOR FOLKS DOCTORS
PSYCHOLOGISTS- YEP COMMITTEE
BASED ORGANIZATIONS I MEAN.
THAT ONE A PARTY AND HELP IT
AND GET INVOLVED. BECAUSE I
MEAN. IT SAID THAT THE UNITED
STATES THE- THAT. WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE WERE
PROTECTING OUR OWN AND I AND I
ALWAYS THEIR OWN I MEAN
CALIFORNIA'S ALWAYS A LEADER-
ARE WE GETTING FOLKS NOW SAYING
HEY WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE READY TO PARTICIPATE AND
I'M ASKED THE QUESTION IS TO
THE PARTICIPANTS I'M I'M
LOOKING AT THE PRIVATE SECTOR
SUPPORT PRIVATE SECTOR SAYING
THEY WANT TO GET INVOLVED ALSO
BECAUSE WE NEED EVERYONE. TO
JOIN IT. IF YOUR QUESTION
DIRECTED TO A CERTAIN PANELISTS
ARE YEAH JUST SUMMER ONE SISTER
WHO OVER WANTS TO. ENSURE THAT.
HI I COULD PERHAPS OFFER A BIT
OF A BIT OF AN ANSWER- IT. IT
IS EXTREMELY COMMON AND AS BEEN
TRUE THROUGHOUT THE TWO AND A
HALF YEARS THAT I WORKED ON
THIS CASE THAT. THERE IS A
STEADY STREAM OF FOLKS. IN AND
OUT OF THE BLUE EVEN SORT OF
SAYING I DON'T EVEN KNOW. WHAT
WAY I COULD HELP BUT IF YOU
COULD THINK OF A WAY. PLEASE
LET ME KNOW PLEASE PUT ME INTO
EFFORTS PLEASE REFER ME TO
VOLUNTEER ORGANIZATIONS THAT-
YOU KNOW HOW FUNCTION AS SORT
OF A MUTUAL AID NETWORK FOR-
SOME OF THE SEPARATED FAMILIES-
AND SO ON AND SO- I THINK THAT.
THE VERY SHORT ANSWER IS YES
STEADILY REGULARLY. PEOPLE TO
REACH OUT FROM FROM ALL AREAS
TO WONDER HOW MIGHT HOW MIGHT
THEY HELP AND IS THERE A WAY
FOR US TO. TO PLUG THEM IN AND
THERE USUALLY IS SOMETIMES IT'S
A LITTLE BIT HARDER THERE ARE-
YOU KNOW FOR SOME OF THAT FOR
EXAMPLE OUR REACH TO SEPARATED
FAMILIES- THOSE TEND TO BE TO
DELEGATE CONVERSATIONS THAT.
CAN'T REALLY HAPPEN THROUGH
SORT OF ALL INTERIOR EFFORTS
NECESSARILY BUT- IN MANY OTHER
WAYS- THAT THAT HELP HAS BEEN
INVALUABLE. CHINA VERY. THE
HEAD. YEAH THIS TIME IN TIME IN
AN ECHO THAT RESPONSE AMERICAN
TO GET IN MY WORKING ON DROWNED
BY MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
AND PEDIATRICIANS WHO ARE
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
IMPACT IN IN OUR ROLES IN THIS
HARM TO CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
THAT REALLY RUSHED TO THE TWO
CALLS TO HER TO RESPOND SO I
HAVE HOPE AND OPTIMISM I KNOW
WHEN I FIRST GOT INVOLVED IN
SOME OF THIS WORK WHEN THEY
WERE COST BUT OUT FOR- FOR
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS TO BE
INVOLVED IN THE MONITORING AND
IMPACT OF. OF SEPARATION
PRACTICES- VISUAL SUPPORT CALL
OUT WAS WAS INUNDATED WAS
OVERWHELMED BY THE NUMBER
SPONSONS THAT THEY RECEIVED- SO
I THINK THERE'S PROMISING
THERE'S HOPE THERE'S MOMENTUM
FOR FOLKS TO TAKE TO GET
INVOLVED UNLESS MR CLINTON
MENTIONED SOMETIMES- IT IT'S
ABOUT FINDING- THAT HAPPENED
AND THE PATHWAYS. WORKS HARD
PROBLEM AND- I THINK IN THE
PAST WE'VE BEEN CHALLENGING
WORKING WITH- YOU KNOW THAT THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION AND
FINING IN FIND WAYS TO ACCESS-
THE KIDS AND FAMILIES THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED SO AGAIN THIS IS
WHERE THERE'S PROMISE WITH THE
NEW ADMINISTRATION- THAT ACCESS
WILL BE MADE A LITTLE IS IT- IN
A LITTLE BIT EASIER- AND- WILL
BE ABLE TO YOU KNOW. CHANNEL
SOME OF THE MOVEMENT AND
PASSIONATE FOLKS ARE BRINGING
TO THIS ISSUE- INTO. TAX WILL
CHANGES SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. OKAY LIVE TO
NOW MOVE ON TO OUR SIDE PANEL
ON TO IMMIGRANT CHILDREN AND
FAMILY- TWENTY THINK THANK THE
FIRST PANEL FOR TESTIMONY- WE
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE TODAY-
ON OUR NEXT PANEL OUR FIRST
WITNESS IS NAY HAAS TO SIGN
WITH THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR.
YOUTH LAW. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON AND STONE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEES ON HUMAN SERVICES
AND JUDICIARY THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO PRESENT TODAY AT
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING. ARE YOU
ALL ABLE TO SEE THE POWER POINT
THAT I HAVE UP. NOT YET- WE CAN
FIFTH PART OF IT- THERE WE GO
NOW WE CAN FIFTH. OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT MY NAME IS
NAY HAD TO SITE AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF IMMIGRATION AT THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOU BOB.
ALSO KNOWN AS NICHOL. NICHOLS A
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
THAT WORKS TO ADVANCE JUSTICE
FOR CHILDREN YOUTH AND A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT SYSTEMS INCLUDING
HEALTH. EDUCATION CHILD WELFARE
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND
IMMIGRATION. OUR IMMIGRATION
WORK SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN ARE ABLE TO
LIVING COMMUNITIES RATHER THAN
IN GOVERNMENT CUSTODY. AND THAT
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO HEAL AND THRIVE. OUR
WORK WEAVES TOGETHER MULTIPLE
TOOLS INCLUDING LITIGATION
POLICY NARRATIVE CHANGE AND
STAKEHOLDER EDUCATION. NICHOLAS
IS COUNCIL ON FLORIDA'S THE
CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT WHICH
RESULTED IN THE LANDMARK
SETTLEMENT IN NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN GOVERNING THE CUSTODY
DETENTION AND RELEASE ALL
CHILDREN IN FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
CUSTODY. OUR WORK MONITORING
THE SETTLEMENT ALONG WITH OUR
WORK IN RELATED CASES WE HAVE
FILES PROVIDE HAS PROVIDED US
WITH TREMENDOUS INSIGHT. INTO
THE EXPERIENCES OF CHILDREN AND
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION CUSTODY AS
WELL AS THE FAILURES OF THE
CURRENT APPROACH. I WAS ASKED
TODAY TO EXPLAIN THE TRAJECTORY.
IN THE CUSTODY OF THE OFFICE OF
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT. WHICH IS
WHERE YOU'D SEPARATED FROM THE
ADULTS WITH WHOM THEY ARRIVED
WOULD BE PLACED. I WILL START
WITH THE FLOW CHART
ILLUSTRATING THE COMPLEX PATH
THAT CHILDREN AND FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION CUSTODY TATE AND
THEN I WILL WALK THROUGH THE
CASE STUDY OF A CHILD'S JOURNEY
THROUGH THIS PROCESS. CHIEF THE
FIRST STOP FOR ALL CHILDREN IN
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION CUSTODY IS
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PROTECTION.
IT IS HERE THAT CHILDREN ARE
CAGED ATTEMPTING TO SLEEP AT
NIGHT AND THEY'RE FREEZING
CELLS UNDER MYLAR BLANKETS WITH
BLINDING LIGHTS LEFT ON ALL
NIGHT. THESE FACILITIES WERE
DESIGNED WITH ADULT MEN IN MIND
AND ARE COMPLETELY
INAPPROPRIATE FOR CHILDREN AND
FRANKLY FRANKLY HUMAN BEINGS.
CHILDREN ARE GENERALLY REQUIRED
TO BE TRANSFERRED OUT OF TPP
CUSTODY WITHIN SEVENTY TWO
HOURS YET FAR TOO OFTEN YOUR
KEPT WELL BEYOND THAT LIMIT.
CHILDREN ARRIVING WITH PARENTS
OR GUARDIANS ALSO KNOWN AS A
COMPANY CHILDREN ARE
TRANSFERRED TO THE CUSTODY OF
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT. CHILDREN DREAM TO
BE UNACCOMPANIED MEANING THAT
THEY'RE ARRIVING WITHOUT
PARENTS OR LEGAL GUARDIANS OR
PARENTS OR LEGAL GUARDIANS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO CARE FOR THEM
TIME. ARE TRANSFERRED TO THE
COPS OFFICE OF REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT NOTICE- ARE ARE.
ANY CHILD THAT IS SEPARATED
FROM AN ADULT WITH WHOM THEY
ARRIVE WHETHER THAT BE A
PARENT. LEGAL GUARDIAN OR AN
ADULT ANOTHER ADULTS IS
TRANSFERRED TO OUR AS WELL.
FROM OUR CHILDREN ARE
ABSOLUTELY RELEASED TO A
SPONSOR GENERALLY A FAMILY IN
THE COMMUNITY I CAN CARE FOR
THEM. SOME CHILDREN RETURN TO
THEIR HOME COUNTRY. IN SOME
CASES VOLUNTARILY IN OTHER
CASES DUE TO APPROVAL ORDER
FROM AN IMMIGRATION JUDGE AND
OTHER CHILDREN AGE OUT OF ICE
BECAUSE OF OUR CUSTODY I'M
SORRY INTO ICE CUSTODY ONCE
THEY TURN EIGHTEEN. THE CASE
STUDY THAT I WANNA SHARE WITH
YOU IS A COMPOSITE OF CLASS
MEMBERS WE INTERVIEWED OVER THE
YEARS. THIS STORY DOES NOT
TRACK THE EXPERIENCE OF ONE
SINGULAR YOU. MCPHAIL'S MOTHER
WAS MURDERED BY HIS STEPFATHER
WHEN HE WAS SEVEN YEARS OLD.
AFTER HER DEATH THE DAILY NEWS
THE BILLINGS WENT TO LIVE WITH
THEIR GRANDMOTHER WHO LIVED IN
AN AREA. THAT WAS CHANGED
CONTROLLED BY GANGS. WORRIED
ABOUT THEIR SAFETY MENTALES
GRANDMOTHER OFTEN KEPT MATTEO
AND HIS SIBLINGS HOME FROM
SCHOOL. GANG MEMBERS REPEATEDLY
THREATENED DOWN HIS OLDER
BROTHER WITH VIOLENCE IF THEY
DID NOT JOIN THE GAME. WHEN
THERE WAS TWELVE YEARS OLD HIS
STEPFATHER ESCAPE FROM PRISON
AND THREATENED TO KILL HIM AND
HIS SIBLINGS. AIRED FOR THEIR
LIVES MATTEO HIS NINETEEN YEAR
OLD BROTHER AND HIS SEVEN YEAR
OLD SISTER FLED FROM. AFTER
TRAVELING FOR WEEKS AND
DANGEROUS CONDITIONS BUT THEY
ON HIS SIBLINGS WERE
APPREHENDED BY C. B. P. AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER. CBP AGENTS
SEPARATED MATT DAMON HIS LITTLE
SISTER FROM THEIR OLDER BROTHER
KEEPING THEM IN A DIFFERENT
AREA OF THE HOLDING FACILITY.
BUT THEY IS OLDER BROTHER WAS
THEN TRANSFERRED TO AN ADULT I
USED TO TENSION. IN LOUISIANA.
WELL I'M A DAY ON HIS LITTLE
SISTER WERE TRANSFERRED TO A
SHELTER IN TEXAS THAT HOUSES
OVER A HUNDRED THE COMPANY
CHILDREN. SCARED MATTEO MEDICAL
STORY ABOUT HURTING PEOPLE IN
LOTUS. HE THOUGHT THIS WOULD
MAKE THE SHELTER STAFF AND
OTHER CHILDREN LEAVE HIM AND
HIS LITTLE SISTER A LOAN. THE
NEXT DAY STAFF WILL COME UP AT
FOUR IN THE MORNING SHACKLETON
AND PUT HIM ON A PLANE TO A
JUVENILE DETENTION CENTER. IN
CALIFORNIA. SATIN THOMAS DALE
WHITE IS BEING MOVED WHERE HE
WAS GOING NOR DID THEY ALLOW
HIM A CHANCE TO SAY GOODBYE TO
HIS SISTER. WITHIN A FEW DAYS
OF HIS ARRIVAL AT THE DETENTION
CENTER BUT THEY- TOLD THE CASE
MANAGER THAT HE HAD MADE UP THE
STORY ABOUT PEOPLE HURTING HIM.
I'M SORRY ABOUT HIM HURTING
PEOPLE. THE CASE MANAGER
RECOMMENDED THAT MCCABE BE
MOVED TO A LESS RESTRICTIVE
FACILITY. WANT TO STEP DOWN WAS
APPROVED BY OUR OUR IT STILL
TAKES A LOT MORE WEEKS BEFORE
HE STEPPED DOWN TO A LESS
RESTRICTIVE FACILITY. WHILE HE
WAS IN DETENTION HE WORRY
CONSTANTLY ABOUT HIS LITTLE
SISTER. HE WAS TERRIFIED. YOU
NEED TO SAY GOODBYE TO HER. HE
COULDN'T UNDERSTAND WHY HE WAS
IN A DETENTION CELL RATHER THAN
BACK AT THE SHELTER WITH HER.
HIS MENTAL HEALTH DETERIORATED
RAPIDLY. AND DURING HIS TIME IN
THE DETENTION CENTER GUARDS
MOCKED HIM USING RACIAL
EPITHETS. ONE NIGHT HE WAS
PEPPER SPRAYED WHEN CAUGHT IN
THE MIDDLE OF A FIGHT BETWEEN
THE GUARD AND ANOTHER USE. SH
MEANWHILE MATTEO AREN'T NAY ANY
SUBMITTED A SPONSORSHIP
APPLICATION IN ORDER TO HAVE
HIM RELEASED HER CARE. SEVERAL
WEEKS LATER SHE WAS INFORMED
THAT SHE WOULD NEED TO UNDERGO
A HOME STUDY AND SUBMIT
FINGERPRINTS AS WELL. WEEKS
AFTER COMPLETING THE HOME STUDY
BUT THERE'S CASE MANAGER CALL
MANDY AND TOLD HER THAT SHE WAS
DENYING. SPONSORSHIP
APPLICATION. THOUGH THE CASE
MANAGER DIDN'T PROVIDE ANYTHING
IN WRITING SHE MENTIONS IN
MIAMI THAT SHE WAS CONCERNED
THAT MY AND HE DID NOT HAVE
ENOUGH SPACE TO ACCOMMODATE
MATTEO SINCE SHE LIVED IN A ONE
BEDROOM APARTMENT. SHE ALSO
SCRAPPED EXPRESSED CONCERNS
ABOUT MALAYS ABILITY TO MEET
MATHIAS MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
DALY HAD NO WAY TO CHALLENGE
THIS DECISION. AND SOME BAIL
REMAINED IN CUSTODY. ARE ARE
SHOULD BE A SAFE PASSAGE FOR
CHILDREN ARRIVING AT OUR
BORDERS RELEASING CAN'T AND
IT'S CARE SWIFTLY WITHOUT
INFLICTING HARM WHILE THEY'RE
IN GOVERNMENT JUST EIGHTY.
LATER THIS WEEK NICKEL WILL BE
RELEASING A SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR CONGRESS
AND HOW TO ACHIEVE THIS. AND
MORE BROADLY TO DEVELOP A NEW
PATH FORWARD. ONE THAT IS BASED
IN CHILD WELFARE PRINCIPLES AND
PROTECT THE DIGNITY HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF ALL MIGRANT CHILDREN.
EVERY SHARE TIME TODAY MOREOVER
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO THE
CHILDREN. ON TO ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU
MR FIVE- WILL HOLD FOR
QUESTIONS TO THE OTHER
PANELISTS HAVE HAD A CHANCE TO
SPEAK IN OUR NEXT SPEAKER IS
ERICA THE OTHER A DIRECTOR
INTERPRETATION AND POLICY I'LL
ORDER LEVEL. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
TODAY. I'LL START WITH A BRIEF
OVERVIEW ABOUT OTHER SERVICES
THAT WE PROVIDE TO IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES I'LL TALK ABOUT OUR
REUNIFICATION. ASIAN PROGRAM
AND THAT TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE SEE AN
SERVING FAMILIES THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN REUNIFIED AND SOME
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORTING THESE
FAMILIES. ARE JUST A START WITH
A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
ORGANIZATION WE ARE BY NATIONAL
LEGAL SERVICE PROVIDER WITH
OFFICES IN LOS ANGELES SAN
DIEGO AND TIJUANA. OUR LOS
ANGELES OFFICE BOTH LEGAL
PROGRAMS. FOCUSED AND SERVICES
FOR UNDOCUMENTED UNINSURED
MIGRANTS AT THE L. A. COUNTY
HOSPITAL AND WE ALSO REPRESENT
MIGRANTS DETAINED AT THE
ADELANTO DETENTION FACILITY.
BACKGROUND SERVICES FOR
REFUGEES RECENTLY RESETTLED AND
COUNTING. IT SAN DIEGO WE
REPRESENT MIGRANTS DETAINED AT
THE O. TIENEN MASSA DETENTION
FACILITY WITH A FOCUS ON THE
LONG DETENTION. WE HAVE A
LITIGATION PROGRAM THAT HAS
EIGHT PENDING CLASS ACTION
CASES ADDRESSING THE RIGHTS OF
ASYLUM SEEKERS AT THE BORDER
AND MIGRANTS IN DETENTION. OUR
BY NATIONAL FAMILY UNITY
PROGRAM FOCUSES ON FORMER
CALIFORNIA. WHO WERE DEPORTED
AND WHOSE CHILDREN ENDED UP IN
CALIFORNIA COUNTY FOSTER CARE
SYSTEMS. AND TIJUANA BASED
MORTAR RIGHTS PROJECT PROVIDES
KNOW YOUR RIGHTS EDUCATION
REPRESENTATION HUMAN RIGHTS-MONITORING ACCOMPANIMENT TO
ASYLUM SEEKERS AT THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE SERVED OVER TEN
THOUSAND REFUGEES AND HOSTED
OVER THREE THOUSAND VOLUNTEERS
IN TIJUANA. TURNING TO OUR
FAMILY REUNIFICATION PROGRAM IT
STARTED ORGANICALLY BECAUSE WE
ARE TWENTY SEVENTEEN STARTED
DOCUMENTING AN UPTICK IN FAMILY
SEPARATIONS AT THE SENATE
FUTURE PORT OF ENTRY.
SEPARATIONS WE DOCUMENTED WHERE
THAT OF US CITIZEN CHILDREN-
EIGHT SEPARATED FROM ASYLUM
SEEKING PARENTS AND THESE ARE
GENERALLY NOT THE TYPES OF
SEPARATIONS BEING ADDRESSED BY
THIS HEARING BUT REPRESENT A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE AT THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER. THE MOST
COMMON FACT SCENARIO WE WOULD
SEE. AARON TO A PRE RELEASE
PREVIOUSLY SPENT TIME IN THE
UNITED STATES HOW DO YOU S.
BORN CHILD AND WENT BACK TO
THEIR HOME COUNTRY VOLUNTARILY.
AFTER FACING PERSECUTION IN
THEIR HOME COUNTRY THEY WOULD
COME BACK TO THE BORDER AND
PRESENT THEMSELVES AT A PORT OF
ENTRY- TO SEEK PROTECTION BUT
BECAUSE CBP CANNOT SEND U. S.
CITIZEN CHILDREN TO ICE
CUSTODY. THEY WOULD CALL SAN
DIEGO COUNTY CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES TO TAKE CUSTODY OF THE
CHILD SO THAT THEY COULD DETAIN
THE PARENT WE NOW KNOW THAT
BETWEEN TWENTY FOURTEEN AND
TWENTY NINETEEN. SAN DIEGO
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES TOOK
CUSTODY OF ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN CHILDREN
FROM C. B. P. ECKLEY
FACILITATING FAMILY SEPARATION.
THIS IS IN ADDITION TO THE
FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED SEPARATED
FAMILIES WE ARE FOCUSED ON
ENTITIES. BY THE END OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE SAW AN INCREASING
NUMBER OF REFUGEE CHILDREN
BEING SEPARATED FROM THEIR
PARENTS APPS AND BETWEEN PORTS
OF ENTRY AND THE NUMBERS
INCREASED EXPONENTIALLY IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS ZERO
TOLERANCE WAS IMPLEMENTED
ACROSS THE BORDER. BY THE TIME
THE ACLU FILED MISS L. VERSUS
ICE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. WE KNEW
THAT AT LEAST FOUR HUNDRED
PARENTS HAD BEEN DEPORTED
WITHOUT THEIR CHILDREN AFTER
BEING SEPARATED. AND THEIR
CHILDREN REMAINED IN THE UNITED
STATES. HELLO THROAT LEVEL
BEGAN WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
MICELLE STEERING COMMITTEE TO
ATTEMPT TO UNIFY THESE DEPORTED
PARENTS WITH THEIR CHILDREN.
THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT FORM
PART OF THE STEERING COMMITTEE
DIDN'T INITIAL SCREENING FOR
THE PARENTS AND REFERRED TO A
LOCAL LEVEL ANY PARENT WITH THE
PROTECTION CONCERNS. BETWEEN
AUGUST AND DECEMBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN HELLO CARRILLO STAFF
SCREEN ABOUT A HUNDRED DEPORTED
PARENTS AND TRAVEL TO CENTRAL
AMERICA ON FIVE SEPARATE
SEPARATE TRIPS TO CONDUCT IN
PERSON INTERVIEWS. ULTIMATELY
OUR ORGANIZATION SUBMITTED
FORTY THREE PETITIONS FOR
RETURN THROUGH THE ACLU IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
AROUND THAT TIME THERE WAS A
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN THAT
INDEFINITELY EXTENDED THE
GOVERNMENT'S DEADLINE TO
RESPOND LEAVING PARENTS
DESPERATE FOR ANOTHER OPTION.
SO IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND JANUARY OF TWENTY
NINETEEN A LOCAL OTHER WAS ABLE
TO OBTAIN MEXICAN VISAS THAT
ALLOW TWENTY NINE OF THE
SEPARATED PARENTS AND THEIR
OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS TO LEGALLY
TRAVEL THROUGH MEXICO. AND WE
HELPED PRESENT THIS GROUP AT
THE BORDER IN MARCH OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. ALL WERE ADMITTED TO
THE UNITED STATES AND OF SINCE
REUNIFIED WITH THEIR CHILDREN.
IT TOOK THE GOVERNMENT OVER A
YEAR TO ADDRESS THE REST OF THE
PETITIONS WE SUBMITTED THROUGH
THE MISALLOCATION IN THE SUMMER
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHT PARENTS FROM%
THAT GROUP. WERE ABLE TO
REUNIFY WITH THEIR CHILDREN
ONLY IN FEBRUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY. ANDSOME MEMBERS OF THE
ORIGINAL CLASS STILL REMAIN
SEPARATED. AS DANIEL GLENDALE
MENTIONED EARLIER IN TWENTY
NINETEEN ACLU SUCCESSFULLY
EXPANDED THE MICELLE CLASS TO
INCLUDE FAMILIES THAT HAVE BEEN
SEPARATED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
SO SINCE LAST YEAR TO ALLOW HAS
BEEN WORKING WITH THE STEERING
COMMITTEE TO IDENTIFY. THESE
PARENTS AND SCREEN THEM TO SEE
IF THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR
UNIFICATION THROUGH THE COURT
PROCESS. SO WE'RE CURRENTLY
REPRESENTING A GROUP OF AROUND
THIRTY PARENTS WERE DEPORTED
WITHOUT CHILDREN AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
ALL OF WHOM WANT TO RETURN TO
THE UNITED STATES TO REUNIFY
WITH THEIR CHILDREN. MOST ARE
IN HIDING AND HAVE SUFFERED
THREATS AND PERSECUTON AFTER
BEING DEPORTED FROM THE UNITED
STATES. WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT THE
BY DEMONSTRATION WILL PROVIDE
DEPORTED PARENTS WITH THE
POSSIBLE RETURN REUNIFICATION.
THESE PARENTS- WHO WERE
DEPORTED WITHOUT THEIR CHILDREN
HAVE VERY FEW RIGHTS UNDER THE
MICELLE SETTLEMENT. AND THE
COURT HAS NEVER ESTABLISHED A
CLEAR PROCESS FOR RETURNING
REUNIFICATION. EVEN IF THE
GOVERNMENT WERE TO STIPULATE
FOR RELIEF FOR DEPORTED PARENTS
THAT ARE CLASS MEMBERS AND THE
MISSILE CASE. VERY FEW WOULD
MEET THE STRICT CRITERIA
ESTABLISHED BY THE JUDGE. THIS
MEANS THAT THE NEED FOR THE
BITING MINISTRATION TO CREATE
AN ACTUAL PATH FOR RETURNING
REUNIFICATION. IS CRITICAL OF
ANY OF THESE PARENTS ARE EVER
GOING TO SEE THEIR CHILDREN
AGAIN. THE COURT HAS ALSO
LIMITED RELIEF TO THOSE PARENTS
FOR THE VIABLE ASYLUM CLAIMS.
EVEN THOUGH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS
INTENTIONALLY LIMITED ASYLUM
PROTECTIONS FOR CENTRAL
AMERICAN MIGRANTS. OUR HOPE IS
THAT THE BLIGHTED
ADMINISTRATION WILL ALSO OFFER
OFFER A FORM OF RELIEF
INDEPENDENT FROM ASYLUM. AND
NOT FORCES PARENTS TO GO
THROUGH AN ADVERSARIAL COURT
PROCEEDING TO GAIN STATUS IN
THE UNITED STATES. CURRENTLY A
LITTLE OTHER WAS WORKING WITH
DOZENS OF FAMILIES THAT WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO REUNIFY ABOUT A
QUARTER OF OUR CLIENTS HAVE
SETTLED IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
REST ARE SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. AS ONE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES MENTIONED EARLIER
REUNIFICATION IS ONLY THE FIRST
STEP THESE FAMILIES HAVE
ENORMOUS NEEDS ACROSS ALL
ASPECTS OF THEIR LIVES. STILL A
LOTTERY LOTTO EMPLOYS A
WRAPAROUND SERVICE MODEL WHICH
MEANS THAT WE ENSURE THAT ALL
OF OUR CLIENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
MEDICAL COVERAGE. MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOOD HOUSING PROBLEM
THE LEGAL ASSISTANCE AND OTHER
SOCIAL SERVICE NEEDS. A
WRAPAROUND SERVICE MODEL RELIES
ON OUR COLLABORATION WITH OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
BENEFITING ALL AGENCIES MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS LIKE SENECA.
MEDICAL PROVIDERS LIKE OUR
PARTNERS AT THE L. A. COUNTY
HOSPITAL. AND CDSS FUNDED LEGAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS IN AREAS NOT
SERVED BY A LOT FOR A LOT OF.
GETTING BENEFITS FOR UNIFIED
FAMILIES CAN BE DIFFICULT.
BECAUSE THEIR CASES ARE STILL
PENDING IN IMMIGRATION COURT SO
THEY DON'T HAVE LEGAL STATUS
AND THEY CAN'T QUALIFY FOR MANY
SERVICES. CHILDREN ARE IN A
BETTER POSITION DUE TO THEIR
ELIGIBILITY FOR MEDICAL IN
CALIFORNIA BUT PARENTS AND
SPONSORS ARE OFTEN LEFT OUT.
UNIFIED FAMILIES HAVE ALSO
SUFFERED IMMENSELY DURING THE
CALL THAT CRISIS. FORTUNATELY
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO RAISE FUNDS
PRIVATELY TO ASSIST FAMILIES
WITH EMERGENCY HOUSING AND FOOD
ASSISTANCE. OTHERWISE AND MANY
WOULD HAVE ENDED UP HOMELESS
AND HUNGRY. TO BE THERE LOST
THEIR JOBS OR AT OR OR ELEVATED
RISK OF KOBE DUE TO THEIR
CENTRAL WORK. CHILDREN STILL
SEPARATED FROM THEIR PARENTS
ARE OFTEN LIVING WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS WERE HAVING A DIFFICULT
TIME SUPPORTING THEM
FINANCIALLY THROUGHOUT THIS
CRISIS. MOVING FORWARD. STILL
CALIFORNIA CAN HELP SUPPORT
REUNIFY FAMILIES BY EXPANDING
ELIGIBILITY FOR BENEFITS TO
INCLUDE PARTS WHAT BEEN
SEPARATED FROM THEIR CHILDREN
AS WELL AS SPONSORS CURRENTLY
CARING FOR CHILDREN WHO ARE
STILL SEPARATED FROM THEIR
PARENTS- I WAS VERY HAPPY TO
HEAR MORE ABOUT THE CDSS
PROGRAMS- AVAILABLE. TO LEGAL
AND SOCIAL SERVICE PROVIDERS
WORKING WITH REUNIFIED FAMILIES
BUT THEY DEFINITELY WILLNEED
TO BE EXPANDED TO MEET MY NEEDS
FIVE FAMILIES. THE STATE CAN
ALSO WORK WITH COUNTY CHILD
WELFARE AGENCIES INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO BORDER COUNTIES
OF SAN DIEGO AND IMPERIAL TO
PROHIBIT AGENCIES FROM
FACILITATING FAMILY SEPARATION
RESULTING FROM INTERNAL
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT OR
BORDER ENFORCEMENT. AND FINALLY
THE STATE CAN INSURE THE ICE
FOLLOWS CALIFORNIA LAWS THAT
PROTECT THE PARENTAL RIGHTS OF
INCARCERATED PARENTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU MISS PIAZZA-
OUR NEXT SPEAKER IS JOHANNA
NEVADA PUT IT. DIRECTOR TO THE
BOARD OF MULTIMEDIA SENECA
FAMILY OF AGENCIES. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU SENATE
COMMITTEE CHAIR STONE. AND ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THE HUMAN
SERVICES AND JUDICIARY
COMMITTEES FOR HOSTING THIS
HEARING MY NAME IS DONNA BORROW
PRESS. I'VE WORKED ON THE
SOCIAL WORKER AND AS A FAMILY
MENTAL HEALTH AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE ADVOCATE FOR TEN YEARS
TODAY I SERVE AS THE DIRECTOR
OF THE BILL THE PONY FROM THE
OPERA GRAMMAR SENECA FAMILY OF
AGENCIES. FANECA WAS FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE AND IS NOW
ONE OF THE LARGEST NONPROFIT
PROVIDERS OF CHILDREN'S
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES ON
THE WEST COAST. FOR OVER THIRTY
FIVE YEARS WE HAVE WORKED TO
SUPPORT THE MENTAL HEALTH
INSTABILITY OF CHILDREN YOUTH
AND FAMILIES OFTEN THROUGH THE
MOST CHALLENGING AREAS OF THEIR
LIVES. IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THANK OFFERED EXPERT TESTIMONY
IN THE MOST JP THE SESSIONS
CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT. PUBLIC
COUNCIL REPRESENTED THREE MY
GRANDPARENTS SEEKING FAMILY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
ADDRESS THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
TRAUMA. OF DETAINMENT. SORRY
AND SEPARATION JUST JOHN A
ORDER REQUIRING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
MENTAL HEALTH SCREENINGS AND
TREATMENTS AT THOUSANDS OF
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES WERE
IMPACTED BY FAMILY SEPARATION
SENATOR WAS AWARDED THE
CONTRACT FROM THE US DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES TO
LOCATE IMPACTED FAMILIES AND
CONNECT THEM TO MENTAL HEALTH
ASSESSMENT AND TREATMENT IN
THIS WAY ADULTERY FAMILIA ALL
FOR MY FAMILY. PROGRAM WAS BORN.
STILL THE CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
WORKING TO LOCATE FAMILIES
IMPACTED BY THE ZERO TOLERANCE
POLICY AND LINK THEM TO
RESOURCES. BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ASSESSMENTS IN TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE SINCE DECEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. DURING THIS
TIME WE HAVE SPOKEN TO MORE
THAN SIX HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS
ACROSS THIRTY STATES WE HAVE
PARTNERED WITH MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MENTAL
HEALTH AND SOCIAL SERVICE.
PROVIDERS NATIONALLY TO PROVIDE
LOCAL REFERRALS TO FAMILY.
CAMELINA ELIGIBLE FOR DELIVERY
FOR ME ARE THOSE THAT WERE
SEPARATED AT THE BORDER BY THE
US GOVERNMENT ON OR AFTER JULY.
FIRST TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AND REMAIN IN THE US. THIS IS
JUST ONE SEGMENT OF THE
POPULATION THAT WAS HARMED BY
THE ZERO TOLERANCE POLICY WELL
CRITICAL OUR SERVICES ARE
LIMITED AND DON'T REACH EVERY
IMPACTED FAMILY. THIS GROUP IS
NOT A MONOLITH EACH FAMILY HAS
A UNIQUE STORY UNIQUE STRENGTHS
AND CHALLENGES. WITH THE
FAMILIES DO HAVE IN COMMON IS
THAT THEY HAVE LEFT OF
SEPARATION CHAOS IN HUMANE
TREATMENT. AND ARE NOW
NAVIGATING A LOT AND I KNOW IN
THE MONTHS AND YEARS FOLLOWING
DETAINMENT. I'D LIKE TO SHARE
TODAY IS THE OVERARCHING
LESSONS FROM PARTNERING WITH
THIS POPULATION OVER THE LAST
YEAR. IMPROPERLY FAMILY OUT WE
APPROACH EACH COMMUNICATION
pAUTOMATED. YEAH MORE THAN THAT
THE LIBERTY TO MEDIA NEW STUDY
OPPOSITE OF. RECORDS GETS ON
THE PHONE IN THE FINAL CITY
THROUGH FOR MEDIA. HI I'M JOE
HUNTER PRESS. CALLING FOR
OPENING THE MEDIA THE DO YOU
LIKE TO HEAR ABOUT THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE. AVAILABLE
TO YOUR FAMILY. SOME PARENTS.
ASK I'VE GOTTEN THERE PHONE
NUMBER. OTHERS ASK IF ACCEPTING
AND THEIR IF. CASES MANY ASKED
ABOUT THE PUBLIC CHARGE OLD
WERE IMMIGRANTS TO THE U. S.
CAN BE DENIED PERMISSION TO
STAY AT THE REQUIRED GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE OR LACK ECONOMICALLY
SOURCES. I THINK THAT HELPED.
IT IS OFTEN NOT EVEN OUR STATE
TO ASK FAMILY IN THIS FIRST
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE HORRIFIC
TRAUMA THEY HAVE. RECENTLY
ENTERED SO WE BOUGHT SHAFT
CONNECTIONS P. FIFTIETH. FAMILY
SICK RESOURCES FOR THE THINGS
THAT ANY FAMILY ME. DIAPERS
THREE INTERNET TAX OBLIGATES
FOR DISTANCE LEARNING SCHOOL
ENROLLMENT SUPPORT LEGAL
SUPPORT. DR THANK YOU FOR THEIR
KIDS MATCHES THE VETTING
TELEPHONES. WE'VE BUILT A
FOUNDATION BY REMAINING A
RELIABLE RESOURCE THAT FAMILIES
CAN COME AND THEY HAVE
BASICALLY. FIFTY TAKES SO MUCH
RESOURCEFULNESS AND CREATIVITY
THEIR COMMUNITIES WHERE
RESOURCES ARE SCARCE THAN
OTHERS. WHERE THERE IS A LOT OF
SUPPORT AVAILABLE. SERVICE
PROVIDER ARE CON BUILD
CONNECTION WITH LOCAL BASE OR-
SO WE CAN MAKE ONE HAND.
BUILDING THE FINISHED
RELATIONSHIP IS CRUCIAL BECAUSE
EVENTUALLY MANY FAMILIES WILL
OPEN UP ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCES
IN DETENTION. AND EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN RECEIVING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. MONSON DIED
SURE THAT THEIR CHILDREN ARE
HYPER VIGILANT AND FEARFUL OF A
THIRTY THINK IT'S KATHLEEN HAVE
RECURRING NIGHTMARES ARE
DISPLAYING AGGRESSIVE BEHAVIOR.
I'M TURN ARE ANGRY AT THEIR
PARENTS WERE LEADING THEM DON'T
SPEAK VERY SUDDENLY SPEAK OR
HAVE TROUBLE FOCUSING ON
SCHOOLS. MAYBE THEY HAVE VERY
LITTLE APPETITE OR INTERESTING
EATING OR HAVE PHYSICAL
SYMPTOMS OF TRAUMA. THE MORE
LETHARGIC OR HAVE SLOWED GROWTH
IT TAKES A LOT FOR PARENTS TO
TRUST US TO SHARE THIS
IFORMATION. I BELIEVE WE AFTER
IT AFTER DARK WITH THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ABOUT THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACT OF THIS
TYPE OF TRAUMA ON INFANTS AND
CHILDREN. AND ADOLESCENTS.
BASICALLY CONSISTENT WITH IF
NOT LIMITED PORTRAYAL OF THE
PHYSICAL MENTAL SYMPTOMS OF.
THE CHILDREN IN CARE IN OUR
PROGRAM. ONCE THE FAMILY.
INTEREST WE WORK HARD. TAKE A
THEM TO MY DAUGHTER IN THE- AND
ABOUT FOR THEM I CALL THIS IS
OF THE HOT HAND ON WE SUPPORT
ACTIONS HAVE. PAYMENT
INFORMATION SHARE WITH FAMILIES
MAKE FACT DURING THE FIRST
VISIT AND SOMETIMES WITH THEIR
NEW PROVIDERS WITHOUT PART OF
RECESSION. THE WE HAVE WORKED
HARD TO THE POINT VEHICLES.
RESOURCE AND PARTNER TO
FAMILIES THEY WILL TELL US IN
THE SERVICE IS WORKING. LIKE
ANY PERSON GOING TO ANY TYPE OF
THERAPY FAMILY THINGTO LIKE
AND TRUST THEIR PERPETRATORS
THAT THEY WILL RETURN. COLD
TEAM HAS DEMANDED EVEN MORE
CREATIVITY. AND ALLOWED US TO
LEVERAGE THE OPPORTUNITY OF
TELEHEALTH. SOME FAMILIES
LIVING IN MORE REMOTE AREAS CAN
ACCESS MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
VIA THEIR OWN. WHERE CAN I
THINK THAT THAT THIS WOULD
OTHERWISE BE DIFFICULT. ANOTHER
LESSON WE LEARNED AGAIN AND
AGAIN. IT IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR
FAMILIES TO SEE MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS THAT SHOW THEIR
CULTURAL IDENTITIES OR DEEPLY
FAMILIAR WITH THEIR IMMIGRATION
MEREDITH. FAMILIES NEED SIX
MINUTES PROVIDERS THAT CAN BE
RESPONSIVE TO THE SIGNIFICANT
DIVERSITY OF ATTITUDES TOWARD
AND EXPERIENCES WITH MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. MANY FAMILIES
HAVE NOT TALKED ABOUT THEIR
CARRIED THE SEPARATION OR WHAT
HAS HAPPENED SEND. IT WITH
THOSE FAMILIES WE ARE PATIENT
WE RESPECT THEIR TIME LINE AND
FOLLOW THEIR LEAD. SO MUCH OF
OUR WORK IS OUT REACH TO GET
THE WORD OUT ABOUT OUR WARM
LINE IN SERVICE LINKAGE
CAPACITY. WE HAVE BEEN FRUITFUL
HAD BEEN GOING DOOR TO DOOR IN
CHIDING FACEBOOK MESSAGING.
WORD OF MOUTH REFERRALS BY
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS AND
LEADERS. FAMILIES WE ABOUT THE
TALKING OTHER FAMILIES ABOUT
THE SERVICES WE CAN OFFER. I
CAN LEAVE YOU WITH A HIGH LEVEL
THOUGHT THIS AFTERNOON IT WOULD
BE THAT WE NEED TO KEEP SHOWING
UP FOR THE FAMILIES. AND I
THINK HE'S FAMILIES I REALLY
MEAN OUR FAMILIES WERE IN THE
SAME COMMUNITIES ARE IN THE
SAME SCHOOLS WERE IN. LINE
TOGETHER AT THE GROCERY STORE.
AND ONCE YOU GET THE TEN
O'CLOCK HOPEFULLY BE AT THE
SAME COMMUNITY EVENT. THE
HEALTHCARE THEY AREN'T
HEALTHIER WE ALL ARE. THE WHAT
ARE PRO IS NOW THE- WE NEED A
SUSTAINED. CULTURALLY SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT FOR THE FAMILIES. AS
THEIR IMMIGRATION STORIES ARE
STILL UNFOLDING. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME MY CEO CAN BEAR IT
ALSO HERE AND HE IS AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE LITIGATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MATH NEVADA PUT S. THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- I
WOULD LIKE TO NOW OPEN IT UP TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR WANT TO CALL YOUR
ATTENTION TO PAGE SIX ROBERT
DRAWING MY FIRST QUESTION FROM
IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THE AC
AC E. STUDY CONCLUDED BY THIS
BY THE CENTER FOR DISEASE
CONTROL- CDC AND KAISER FOUND
THAT YOU WERE TALKS ABOUT THE
TRAUMA THINGS OF THAT NATURE-
THAT THAT THESE CHILDREN ARE
GOING THROUGH MY FIRST QUESTION
IS. HOW HOW DO WE ADDRESS THE
LEGAL AND REMORSE AN EMOTIONAL
CULTURAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
THROUGH LITIGATION. SO THAT'S
MY FIRST QUESTION MY SECOND
QUESTION WOULD BE I KNOW WE THE
NUMBER OF THESE CHILDREN THE
BULK OF MY HAVE COME FROM
CENTRAL AMERICAN AND OTHERS.
HAVE OTHER CHILDREN WHO
POSSIBLY WERE UNDOCUMENTED FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES BEEN ALSO SWEPT
UP- ALSO- ARE HAVING A HARD
TIME REAP CONNECTING WITH THEIR
FAMILIES. MISTER GIBSON SAID
DIRECTED TO- SHAHADAH OR
WHOEVER CAN ANSWER ANYBODY HAVE.
ANYONE ON THE PANEL CAN ANSWER
PLEASE. I COULDN'T SPEAK- AT
LEAST JUST FOR A FEW BRIEF
COMMENTS IN RESPONSE- IN TERMS
OF. ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF THE
FAMILIES THROUGH LITIGATION-
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM SENECA
MENTIONED THERE WAS A CASE THAT
MANDATED THE GOVERNMENT TO PAY
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES- I
KNOW THE SENATE HAS BEEN A
BENEFICIARY OF THAT- THERE'S
ALSO- OTHER CASES THAT WERE
FILED KIND OF IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE MASALA EDUCATION. THAT
TALKED ABOUT- GIVING PARENTS AT
LEAST KIND OF ANOTHER SHOT AT
SOME OF THE IMMIGRATION
PROCEEDINGS DUE TO THE FACT
THAT THEY WERE SO- MENTALLY
AFFECTED BY THE SEPARATION WHEN
THEY INITIALLY- WE'RE GOING
THROUGH THE IMMIGRATION PROCESS
SO PEOPLE HAVE HAD THEIR-
WHAT'S CALLED CREDIBLE FEAR
INTERVIEWS DENIED TO GET
ANOTHER BITE AT THE APPLE
SENSUALLY BECAUSE OF THE-
MENTAL ANGUISH THAT SEPARATION
HAD CAUSED- I CAN STATE AS TO
YOUR SECOND QUESTION. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE FAMILIES FOR
SEPARATED WERE FROM CENTRAL
AMERICA CURRENTLY WE'RE WORKING
WITH SEVERAL WHO ARE MEXICAN
FAMILIES AS WELL- AND I KNOW
THAT THE MAIN PLAINTIFF THE NAY
PLAINTIFF AND MISS I'LL- WAS
ACTUALLY FROM AFRICA SO THERE
WERE FAMILIES THAT WERE FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT WERE SWEPT
UP IN THE US BUT THE VAST
MAJORITY- WHO WERE DEPORTED
WITHOUT THEIR CHILDREN WERE
FROM CENTRAL AMERICA. SOME FROM
MEXICO- PEOPLE FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES GENERALLY WERE STILL
IN DETENTION AT THE TIME THAT
THE MICELLE COURT MANDATED
REUNIFICATION SO WE'RE NOT
SEEING THE SAME KIND OF ISSUES
IN TERMS OF. NOT BEING ABLE TO
FIND PARENTS FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
VENTURE FIVE MASS OF THE
QUESTION YES- YOU MENTION NOT
YOU PARTICULARLY THE LAST THE
LAST VISITOR YOU MENTIONED THAT
PARENTS WHO- WHO BANNED I'M
SEPARATED FROM THEIR CHILDREN
AND SPONSORS WHO CARE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN DO NOT MEET
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS FOR
WRAPAROUND SERVICES TO UNIT
UNIFIED. FAMILIES WHY IS THAT
WHY IS THAT THAT THEY DON'T
MEET THE ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS. FOR RESOURCES.
ONE IS TAT DIRECTLY TO ANY OF
THE PANEL STRIP WHERE ONCE.
THEY WERE HERE THEY CAN-
RESPOND WITH ANY WITH ANY OF
THE PANELISTS CAN RESPOND. I'M
I'M HAPPY TO- I'M CAN DIRECT
THE OF SENECA SO WHAT MOST
WRAPAROUND SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW ARE GEARED
SPECIFICALLY FOR YOUTH AND
CHILD WELFARE AND LIMITED TO
THAT POPULATION OBVIOUSLY. OF
THE YOUTH- IN THESE PROGRAMS
AREN'T IN CHILD WELFARE I ALSO
WANTED TO ADD TO. WHAT THE
LIMITS OF THE LITIGATION. OF
THE BIT THAT- MARK ROSENBAUM OF
PUBLIC COUNSEL FOR WE ARE VERY
VERY NOW AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- LIMITS HAS VERY
STEEPLY TO BILLS AND SOAK. UP
SOME OF THE INTERVENTIONS THAT
JOHANNA POINTED OUT ARE ONES
THAT WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN ABLE
TO DO. IT ALSO REFERS TO A
EARLIER QUESTION ABOUT PRIVATE
SECTOR SUPPORT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO BRING IN. SOME VERY LIMITED
PRIVATE. SECTOR SUPPORT TO DO
THINGS THAT ARE NOT WITH IN THE
LITIGATION IT'S FAIRLY SILLY TO
OFFER SOMEONE. WHO'S REALLY
REALLY HUNGRY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THOSE BASIC NEEDS FIRST. AND
ONCE WE DO THAT AND DEVELOP A
BASIS OF TRUST WE MOVED FORWARD
TO MAKE MENTAL HEALTH AND
OTHER. TYPES OF SERVICES AND
ERICA FOR THE STERLING OF THE
LEGAL SERVICES ARE ABSOLUTELY
IMPERATIVE. CHEER ALL OF THE
TIME BUT YOUR LEGAL STATUS
YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
WORK TO MAKE YOUR FAMILY HOLE
AFTER THE TRAUMA EXPERIENCE. SO
WE'RE ABLE TO CREATE TEAMS TO
PUT TO ALL THOSE THINGS
TOGETHER AND RIGHT NOW THE
LITIGATION ALONE DOESN'T ALLOW
US TO DO THOSE THINGS. WE'VE
ALSO BEEN FORTUNATE TO GET OUT
ON MEDIA TO GET THE WORD OUT-
USING CELEBRITIES- FACEBOOK
ANNOUNCEMENTS AT CETERA BUT WE
HAVEN'T. FULLY PENETRATED THE
POPULATION BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
KNOWN UNTIL VERY RECENTLY ALL
OF THE MEMBERS AND. THE CLASS
WAS VERY LIMITED. THANK VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU- AND BEFORE WE
HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTION I JUST
I APOLOGIZE I WANTED GO BACK
TO- IS YOUR- OF JONATHAN A YOU
HAVE A STORY TO SHARE WITH US
REGARDING NELSON. THANK YOU I
HAVE A TESTIMONY. AN HOUR
WHATEVER CLASS MEMBERS REFER I
FELT I READ IT HELLO MY NAME IS
MELVIN A FEW YEARS AGO I LEFT
MY COUNTRY OF EL SALVADOR TO
COME TO THE UNITED STATES. I
DID THIS TO SAVE MY LIFE AS I
WAS RECEIVING DEATH THREATS IN
MY COUNTRY THAT I WAS GOING TO
BE KILLED I DECIDED TO SEEK
ASYLUM IN THE US WITH MY SON WE
CROSSED THE RIVER AND ARRIVED
AT THE BORDER THEY WERE
APPREHENDED BY IMMIGRATION AND
I EXPLAIN TO THEM WHY WE WERE
THERE. THEY ASKED ME FOR ALL
THE DOCUMENTS I BROUGHT WITH ME
AND FROM THERE THEY TOOK US TO
TWO DIFFERENT ATTENTION CENTER
MYSELF IN ONE AND MY SON IN
ANOTHER WHEN I ASKED HIM THEM
WHERE THEY WERE TAKING MY SON
THEY TOLD ME THEY WERE GOING TO
TAKE HIM TO ANOTHER FAMILY SO
THEY COULD ADOPT HIM. AFTER
THAT MOMENT I DID NOT KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT MY SON FOR TOO
MUCH WHEN MY SON AND I WERE
REUNITED HE TOLD ME THAT HE
CRIED EVERY DAY BECAUSE HE
MISSED ME SO MUCH HE WROTE ME
LETTERS EVERY DAY AND HE ASKED
I THINK TENSION CENTER OFFICERS
FOR ME EVERY DAY UNTIL HE FOUND
ME AGAIN. H. YOU PICTURES OF.
ME AND OUR FAMILY TOGETHER. IF
ME GREATLY. AND I CANNOT
IMAGINE HOW IT AFFECTED HIM AS
A CHILD. EVERYTHING THAT
HAPPENED TO US ON OUR JOURNEY.
HAS HAD A MAJOR EFFECT ON OUR
MENTAL HEALTH. WE WERE
SEPARATED AND I WAS WITH OTHER
PARENTS WHO ARE SEPARATED FROM
THEIR CHILDREN. I TRIED TO BE
STRONG FOR THEM. AND SUPPORT
THE OTHER PARENT. BUT WHEN YOU
START TO SEE OTHER PARENTS
BEGIN TO WEAKEN AND BEGAN TO
pWEAK AND SUFFER. MY HAIR
STARTED TO FALL OUT FROM ALL
THE STRESS AND I HAD SEVERE
HEADACHES. THE SEPARATION
AFFECTED MICE AND GREATLY. AT
THE BEGINNING HE WOULD HAVE
DREAMS THAT WE WEREN'T TOGETHER
AND WOULD WAKE UP. THINKING
HE HAD MANY NIGHTMARES. I DON'T
WAKE UP FEELING SCARED. WHEN I
RECEIVED A CALL FROM SENECA AND
THAT'LL PUT ME COMING UP
PROGRAM I WAS HAPPY. IT WAS A
JOY FOR ME TO HEAR THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS AVAILABLE. IT WAS
VERY GOOD FOR ME AND FOR MY
SON. WE'RE NOT RECEIVING LOTS
OF HELP FROM A THERAPIST THAT
HAS. HELPED MY FAMILY GREATLY
I'VE NOTICED SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES IN HIM. MY SON HAS TOLD
ME THAT HIS THEIR PROCESS HELP
THEM VERY MUCH. HE HAS LEARNED
RELAXATION EXERCISES AND
TECHNIQUES SO HE CAN REMIND
HIMSELF. THAT WE'RE TOGETHER
AND WE ARE SAFE. YOU FINALLY
HAVING A LOT LESS NIGHTMARES.
LITTLE BY LITTLE HE IS GETTING
BETTER. THE SIMPSONS OF THE
TRAUMA THAT HE XPERIENCED THAT
NOW ARE MUCH LESS THAN THEY
WERE BEFORE. MY DREAM JUST LIKE
EVERY FATHER IS TO HELP MY
CHILDREN GET AHEAD AND MOVE
FORWARD. I WANT TO SEE MY
CHILDREN SUCCEED. FROM OF A
HOLD BACK. AND WAIT TO BE
REUNITED. RIGHT NOW MY WIFE AND
OTHER CHILDREN. ARE STILL IN MY
HOME COUNTRY HEALTH WHAT ARE.
BUT THREE FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA THIS TO REUNIFY OUR
WHOLE FAMILIES BUT CANNOT
RETURNS HER HOME COUNTRY'S AND
SOME FAMILY MEMBERS CANNOT MAKE
THE JOURNEY HERE. IN MY CASE
WITH MY WIFE AND MY TWO OTHER
CHILDREN THEY DID NOT COME WITH
US BECAUSE MY WIFE WAS ABOUT TO
GIVE BIRTH TO MY YOUNGEST CHILD
IT WAS VERY PAINFUL FOR MY WIFE
WITH ON OFF OUT THE DOOR. TO
WATCH THE NEWS AND SEE THAT
CHILDREN ARE BEING SEPARATED
FROM THEIR PARENTS AND BEING
PLACED IN DETENTION CENTER. IT
WASN'T UNTIL I WAS RELEASED
FROM THE DETENTION CENTER BUT I
REALIZED I WAS IN TEXAS AND MY
PHONE WAS ALL THE WAY IN NEW
YORK. I COULDN'T BELIEVE HE WAS
ALL THE WAY OVER THERE
THOUSANDS OF MILES AWAY FROM ME
MY FAMILY SUFFERED VERY MUCH
BECAUSE THEY DID NOT KNOW WHAT
WAS GOING TO HAPPEN TO US.
THERE BEEN MANY CONSEQUENCES.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THIS TRAUMA.
THERE ORGANIZATIONS CAL. LIKE
FENNICA. THAT THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD SUPPORT BECAUSE THEY'RE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE TRULY
SUPPORTING SEPARATED FAMILIES.
THE GOVERNMENT WOULD CONTINUE
SUPPORTING ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
CANADA. AND THE BILL. I'M SO
THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE HELPING
ALL OF THE OTHER FAMILIES LIKE
MINE. MY FAMILY IS VERY
GRATEFUL FOR WELCOMING FAMILIA
pSTERLING HELPED IN DON'T KNOW
THAT IT IS AVAILABLE I HOPE
THAT ANYONE. WHO HAS NOT
RECEIVED HELP YET LISTEN TO MY
WORDS AND ACCEPT THE HELP THEY
ARE OFFERING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH- DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. NO TRIVENI COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- IF I CAN MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT PANEL ADDRESSING
ONGOING NEEDS OF THESE
FAMILIES- WE WILL BEGIN WITH
HOLLY COOPER CO DIRECTOR OF THE
UC DAVIS SCHOOL OF LAW'S
IMMIGRATION LAW CLINIC WELCOME
HOLLY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
STONE INVITATION IN THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING HERE TODAY I
TRIED TO- ELIMINATE DUPLICATIVE
TESTIMONY AFTER HEARING ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS PANELISTS TODAY
HOW MANY OF WHOM ARE CLOSE
FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES- IN
THIS. THE LAST FOUR YEARS- SO I
WAS INVITED TODAY. TO DISCUSS
THE NEED FOR INFORMED CONSENT
PROCEDURES FOR IMMIGRANT
CHILDREN WHO ARE. IN THE
CUSTODY OF THE OPPOSITE THAT
THE SETTLEMENTS- OFTENTIMES-
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN SUFFER
CONTINUING WITH TRAVELERS IS
WHAT WE'VE HEARD TODAY FROM-
IT'S BEEN YET- AS WELL AS FROM-
JUST DECIDE. AND PART OF THOSE
CONTINUING TRAUMAS. IS THE
FAMILY SEPARATION. AND THAT
OFTENTIMES THE SAYS THE NEED
FOR APPROACH TO BE ADMINISTERED.
MEDICATION WHAT I WILL FOCUS MY
TESTIMONY ON TODAY IS THE LACK
OF PROPER PROCEDURES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS THAT- THE SECOND
PROGRAMS ARE BEING ADMINISTERED
WITH INFORMED UNDERSTANDING.
FOR BOTH THE PARENTS THE
CHILDREN AND THE FAMILY
MEMBERS- WHO ARE ACTING AS
GUARDIANS FOR CHILDREN. I ALSO-
THAT WAS ASKED TO PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF OUR CLINICS
WORK AND THEN AT THE END OF
ALSO DETAILS SOME CONCRETE
PROPOSALS I BELIEVE THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA COULD
UNDERTAKE- TO ADDRESS THESE
DEFICIENCIES WITHIN OUR- AS THE
NEXT PANELS WILL DISCUSS MANY
OF THESE OR FACILITIES ARE
LOCATED WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND ARE LICENSED BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE- AN
OBLIGATION AND AN ABILITY. TO
RECTIFY SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WE WILL DISCUSS THIS PANEL.
FIRST OF ALL I CO DIRECTOR UC
DAVIS IMMIGRATION HAWK CLINIC
WHICH IS ALSO AN HONOR. AND ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT FACETS OF
OUR COMMUNITY IS THAT WE ALL
FEEL GAVE AN EXPERIENCE OF
LEARNING FOR ALL STUDENTS. ONE
OF THE GREAT THINGS ABOUT A
LOT. OF THAT WERE PRIMARILY
INVOLVED BY STUDENTS OF COLOR
OUR STUDENTS WHO ARE OFTEN
FIRST OR SECOND GENERATION
IMMIGRANTS THEMSELVES INTO
THESE ISSUES ARE VERY CLOSE TO
THE HEART. AND OFTEN THEY ARE
THE ONES WHENEVER YOU SEE MY
NAME JUST REALLY UNDERSTAND OR
MY WORK IT'S REALLY THE WORK OF
THE STUDENTS- MANY OF WHOM WERE
IMMIGRANTS THEMSELVES- ARE THAT
HAVE HELPED SUPPORT THE
LITIGATION. AND ALL THE PROFILE
OF OUR CLINICS WORK SO I REALLY
WANTED TO TAKE MYSELF OUT OF
THE SPOTLIGHT I RECOGNIZE. THAT
I'M ONLY HERE TODAY BECAUSE OF
THE WORK OF THE STUDENTS. AND
BECAUSE. ALSO THE TRUST OF OUR
CLIENTS. THIS CALL. AND LAST
YEARS THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
HE IN THE WORK SEVERAL. THAT
MANY WHICH I'M- OF THE TEAM
DINNER. WE JUST THE CASE LAST.
THE CALL OF IN YOUTH. WHO ARE
ALSO ARRESTED AND CHARGED WITH
WITH GAME. OF THE TRUMP. AND
NOT WORRY IN LONG ISLAND ANY OF
THEM AND BROUGHT TO CALIFORNIA
TO GO COUNTY JAIL- DURING THE
TENURE OF THE REMOVAL
PROCEEDINGS. WE WERE ABLE TO
SEE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
SETTLED THE CASE. TO PROVIDE
PROPER PROCEDURES FOR CHILDREN
BEFORE THEY'RE ARRESTED OFF THE
STREETS IT'S TAKEN FROM THEIR%
FAMILIES AND FOUGHT ALL THE WAY
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES FOR
THE TENSION REMOVAL. WELL WE
ALL WORKS- WITH MISS TO SIGN
OTHERS ON THE BECAUSE OUR
LITIGATION. WHERE WE'RE
SPEAKING TO IMPROVE PROCEDURES
LIKE CONDITIONS FOR CHILDREN
HELD IN FEDERAL CUSTODY. AS
WELL AS I WORK FOR ABOUT FIVE
YEARS ON THE FOR A SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT WILL BE ABLE TO GET.
BASIC MINIMUM STANDARDS OF CARE
FOR CHILDREN IN FEDERAL CUSTODY.
AS WELL AS BOND HEARINGS FOR
CHILDREN. NOW FOCUS MY
TESTIMONY ON THE LACK OF
INFORMED CONSENT PROCEDURES FOR
CHILDREN IN OUR CUSTODY. BUT I
THINK LIKE MANY OF MY CO
PANELIST IT'S ALSO NECESSARY TO
UNDERSTAND. THAT FAMILY
SEPARATION IS BUT ONE OF A
MULTITUDE OF TRAUMAS.
OFTENTIMES JUST LEAVING THE
HOME COUNTRY OR THE COUNTRY OF
ORIGIN FOR THE CHILD ON THIS
PHONE IS A TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCE. IN AND OF ITSELF. I
THINK THE OFFICE LOSING A
FAMILY SEPARATION IS BEING AT
THE BORDERBUT OFTENTIMES
FAMILY SEPARATION STARTS IN THE
HOME COUNTRY. CHILDREN OFTEN
MAKING THE HARD DECISION WITH
PARENTS OR GUARDIANS OF
SIBLINGS TO LEAVE THEIR
COUNTRIES INTO MIGRATED HERE TO
THIS COUNTRY A LOT. OF THE VAST
MAJORITY OVER 80% THE KIDS IN
FEDERAL CUSTODY LATEST VERSION.
TO COME HERE AS AN
UNACCOMPANIED MINOR. ALSO THERE
IS THAT STEP. SO THERE'S THE
PARTNERS. IS ALSO THE PROBLEM
OF MIGRATION- OFTENTIMES A LOT
OF OUR CLIENTS CALL MEXICO THE
VERTICAL BORDER. THERE'S A LOT
OF TIMES DURING THE TRAVERSE
THROUGH THE COUNTRY OF MEXICO
POPE JOHN OR EXPLOITED- WE'VE
HEARD STORIES. BUT I WOULDN'T-
EVEN TALK ABOUT IN FRONT O
THIS ASSEMBLY BECAUSE EXPOSURE
MATIC- THERE'S SO THERE'S THE
EXPLOITATION PROMISE OF
MIGRATION. AND THEN ONCE THEY
MAKE IT TO THE UNITED STATES
THEY'RE ARRESTED AND OFTENTIMES
CAGE DISMISS DECIDED
ELOQUENTLY- SPOKE OF THEIR
OFTENTIMES PUT IN THE ORDER
SHALL CAGES. I'M VERY INTIMATE
CONDITIONS AS WELL AS A HORROR
CUSTODY SO THERE'S WHAT WE CALL
THE DETENTION TRAUMA ITSELF.
THE TIME OF THE TRIAL ARRIVES
OFFICER PRODUCE CUSTODY. THERE
CAN OFTEN. YES I CAN. BREAKDOWN
OF THE CHILD. WE HAVE TALK WITH
LOCAL. A REPRESENTED WHO HAVE
ATTEMPTED SUICIDE WHILE IN
CUSTODY. WHERE WE HAD A CLIENT
TO IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
ATTEMPTED TO HANG HIMSELF IN
THE BATHROOM. DUE TO THE
ENORMOUS TRAUMA THAT HE HAD
WITNESSED IN HIS HOME COUNTRY
HOWEVER WHEN HE WAS INTERVIEWED
BY THE PSYCHIATRIST WELL HE WA
DIAGNOSED WITH OPPOSITIONAL
DEFIANT DISORDER BECAUSE THE
PSYCHOLOGIST NEVER MEETING
COREY. INTO THE FACT THAT HE
HAD JUST FLED AND WITNESSED HIS
FAMILY BEING MASSACRED IN THIS
WHOLE COUNTRY AND THESE ARE THE
TYPES OF THINGS THAT WE CAN OF
THE STATE FOR LICENSING ARM
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS LEGAL
PROFESSIONALS CAN REQUIRE IS AN
EDUCATIONAL COMPONENT OF THAT
LICENSURE SO THAT WE NEVER HAVE
A CHILD MISDIAGNOSIS. OR UNDER
DIAGNOSED- FROM THE PRODUCT THE
TRAUMAS THAT THEY'VE ENTERED
BOTH IN THE MIGRATION AS WELL
AS IN THEIR HOME COUNTRIES AS.
WELL AS IN THIS COUNTRY SO-
OFTENTIMES WILL A CHILD GIVEN
LIKE. MEDICATION THAT THEY MAY
NEED IT FOR WHAT WE WANT TO
ENSURE. OF MY TESTIMONY TODAY
IS THE WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
RESIDENTS UNDERSTANDING OF THE
USE OF THOSE THOSE MEDICATIONS
ON CHILDREN. WHAT WE'VE SEEN
OFTENTIMES THERE'S A STAFFERS
DETENTION FACILITIES CONSENTING
ON BEHALF OF THE PARENT.
ANOTHER WORDS WE ARE RENDERING
OFTENTIMES INVISIBLE THE LATINO
FAMILY THE PARENT THE PARENTAL
AGENCY THAT THEY HAVE AND
SHOULD HAVE OVER THEIR
CHILDREN. SOMETIMES WHEN
PARENTS ARE NOT IN THE PICTURE
BUT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE PROPER PROCEDURES AND
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE SO THAT WE
CAN RESPECT. THE IDENTITY AND
AGENCY OF A LATINO FAMILY NOT
JUST A LATINO FAMILY BUT A
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF THESE
CHILDREN ARE INDIGENOUS. THANK
YOU COMING TO THIS COUNTRY.
INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE LANGUAGES
ENCOURAGES CULTURES SO DON'T
WANT TO REPEAT OUR OWN HISTORY
AS A COUNTRY. OF RENDERING
INVISIBLE. AGENCY OR FAMILIES
OF COLOR WHO ARE COMING TO THIS
COUNTRY OR. EVEN WHOEVER NEEDED
TO THIS COUNTRY- WE ALSO NEED
TO ASSESS THE USER PUBLIC. USED
MULTIPLE. DRUGS ON. AT THE SAME
TIME. WE ALSO MET WITH CHILDREN
WITHIN OUR OWN WHO HAVE TOLD US
THAT THEY HAVE THE- ONLY PEPPER
SPRAYED BUT OFTENTIMES DUE TO
PSYCHIATRIC HAVE BEEN FORCIBLY
SEDATED. AND THIS IS WHERE THE
STOCK FOR DETENTION FACILITY IS
CONSENTING ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILD FOR THIS THIS TREATMENT.
THIS IS NOT TO SAY THAT
PSYCHIATRIC DRUGS OR
MEDICATIONS CAN NEVER BE GOOD
FOR CHILD OFTEN THEY CAN BE
VERY BENEFITS WHICH FILE. BUT
WHAT WE ARE HERE TO SAY IS THAT
CONSENT IS A VERY UNIQUE FOR
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN. AS MANY
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT THE
TENDENCIES AND THE DETENTION
ITSELF IS INHERENTLY COERCIVE.
THE CHILDREN AS MR SITE
ELOQUENTLY PUT IN HER CHART
FORTEAN CONCURRENTLY IN REMOVAL
PROCEEDINGS. SO WHEN YOU'RE
TELLING A CHILD HE HAS THE
ABILITY TO FOUR MAY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO REFUSE MEDICATION.
IT'S A DONE BY YOU KNOW TO A
STAFFER WITH THE CHILD FEELS
OCCURS INHERIT YOU KNOW CORSON
BYRON MEANT THAT THEY MUST
APPLY TO THE U. S. GOVERNMENT
ASKING IT TO DO FOR FEAR OF
DISRUPTING THEIR ASYLUM
APPLICATION. TO THESE UNIQUE
ASPECTS OF IMMIGRANT CHILDREN
IN CUSTODY MUST BE CONSIDERED
WHEN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
WORKING WITH THE OFFICE OF
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENTS DEVELOP-
PROTOCOLS AND STANDARDS FOR HOW.
TO ADMINISTER PSYCHIATRIC
MEDICATION. INFORMED IF IT CAN
PROCEDURES BE SAFE MUST BE
EFFECTIVE THEY MUST PROMOTE THE
CHILD'S BEST INTEREST. AND THEY
ALSO LOST- USED AS A MODEL WITH
A CALIFORNIA'S ON FOSTER CARE
PROCEDURES THAT IT'S IT THAT
IT'S THAT IT'S STUDY IN DEPTH.
AS WELL AS THE AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF. PEDIATRICS AND LOOKED AT
THESE FOR INFORMED CONSENT
PROCEDURES- DEVELOP POLICIES
WITH CLARITY WHAT THE OFFICE OF
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT WHERE THEY
HAVE A DETENTION FACILITY. TO
SHELTER CARE FACILITIES IN THE
STATE. THE ASKED IS THAT THE
COULD DEPRIVE COULD CENTER MUST
BE IDENTIFIED AND WE MUST
CONSIDER THE CHILD'S PARENTS.
AS A POTENTIAL CONSIDERED TO
NEED MEDICATION. OFTENTIMES IN
HERE BECAUSE OF HER PARENTS
OUTSIDE OF THE COUNTRY. IT IS
TOO POOR TO AFFORD OF THE PHONE
OFTENTIMES THEIR DAY BEST OF
THIS DECISION MAKING AUTHORITY
OVER THEIR OWN CHILDREN AND AT
THE STATE WE CANNOT STAND BY
THIS TYPE OF A PROTOCOL. SO WE
MUST CONSIDER THEM AS IT WAS
WITHIN THE AMBIT OF THE POWER
AND TO DECIDE ON BEHALF OF
THEIR OWN CHILD EVEN WHILE
THEY'RE IN FEDERAL CUSTODY-
MOREOVER- A CHILD MUST HAVE
BEEN FOR THE FAMILY MUST HAVE
AN INFORMED UNDERSTANDING WHAT
THE DIRECTIONS ARE. WHAT THE
SIDE EFFECTS ARE NOW WITH THE
GOOD SORT OF WAITING THE GOOD
AND THE BAD TO COME TO AN
INFORMED UNDERSTANDING SO THAT
THEY CAN MAKE CHOICES VERY
TOUGH CHOICES. FOR THEIR
CHILDREN OR WHERE THE PARENT IS
NOT AVAILABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE APPROPRIATE AUTHORITIES-
THE PROPRIOCEPTIVE. PERSON IS
APPOINTED TO ASSIST THE CHILD.
BUT IN CONCRETE RECOMMENDATIONS
THE WE HAVE PUT TOGETHER IS
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CAN HELP BECAUSE OUR
POLICY DOES REQUIRED STUDENTS.
TO FOLLOW STATE LAW THE RIVER
BELIEVE IT OR BECAUSE OF A-
NEEDS THIS SORT OF CLARITY FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND I
THINK IT'S TO HELP ORDERFELT
POLICIES AND PRACTICES. AND
GUIDELINES TO HOWTO SAFELY
ADMINISTER PSYCHOTROPIC DRUGS.
FOR CHILDREN. THIRTEEN WITHIN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- WE
WOULD ALSO THE CAL. TO STORE
CAME. FOR IT INFORMED CONSENT-
MUCH OF LIKE WHAT IT ALREADY
DOES IN IN THE STATE SYSTEM.
WELL WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S THE ISSUE OF REFUSAL OF
MEDICATION MANY OF THE CHILDREN
WHO MIGHT NOT HAVE TOLD ME THAT
WHEN THEY REFUSE MEDICATIONS
ARE GIVEN A SPECIAL INCIDENT
REPORT THE PROLONGS THEIR STAY
IN CUSTODY. SO THEY FEEL THAT
THEY CAN BE AN ADVERSE IMPACT
FOR THEM TO REACH YOU REFUSE TO
TAKE THE MEDICATION SO NOT ONLY
SHOULD THERE BE INFORMED
CONSENT PROCEDURES BUT THERE
SHOULD BE AN UNDERTAKING TO
DEVELOP PROPER PROTOCOLS FOR
CHILD. NEEDED TO HAVE SOME
AGENCIES WILL BE ABLE TO AFFORD
THESE MEDICATION WITHOUT
PROLONGING HIS OR HER STAY IN
CUSTODY OVERCROWDING TYPE OF
INCIDENT REPORT THAT COULD
ADVERSELY IMPACT THEM. FOR
THEIR ASYLUM CASE. CALIFORNIA
HAVE A ROLE ALSO KNOWN. OF IN
WAY. I THINK THAT THING THAT
THE BEEN OVERLOOKED HERE TODAY
IS THE FOURTH. OF THE U. S.
GENERAL'S WITHIN THE STATE-
ARRESTING. FAMILY MEMBERS AND
THEM OR OF FAMILY. I WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT LAWYERS WORKING
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR.
LICENSED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. YEAH BLOOD STARTED
OR TRAINING. UNDERSTAND THE
CULTURE IN THE LONG TERM
IMPACT. OF FAMILY SEPARATION.
ON. ALL OF THE CASES THAT THEY
ASSISTED. MOREOVER BECAUSE THIS
HAS. THE EASTERN THE SHOOTER AS
OTHER PEOPLE HAVE. HAVE
MENTIONED- WHICH IS SPEARHEADED
BY THE SURGEON GENERAL. I WOULD
ALSO RECOMMEND FOLDING INTO
THAT STUDY. ALSO PROPER
PROCEDURES AND PROTOCOLS FOR
CHILDREN FEDERAL CUSTODY WITHIN
THE STATE- AND ALSO JUST PROPER
TRAINING OF MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY. AND DIAGNOSE THE
NEWCOMERS IMMIGRANT CHILDREN
THE DOOR NUMBER FOUR- LAWMAKERS
IN HERE FOR THE COMPLETE
SATISFACTION. VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU MR FIVE GATE- OUR NEXT
PRESENTER IS OR HOLE THOMAS
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRATION POLICY
CENTER. HI JUST MAKE SURE
EVERYONE CAN HEAR ME. I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU GUYS COULD SEE ME.
HOW. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU MISTER
THOMAS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
COMMITTEE CHAIRS MEMBERS AND
STAFF FOR CONVENING THIS
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TODAY
ALSO THANK YOU TO THE OTHER
PANELISTS FOR SUCH INSIGHT AND
GREAT STORIES ABOUT THE NEED.
FOR WHY WE NEED TO THINK
THROUGH REUNIFICATION REPORT MY
NAME IS ARGHA THOMAS AND I HAVE
THE HONOR OF SERVING AS THE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
THE CALIFORNIA POLICY CENTER
ORGANIZATION HAS SERVED
CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRANT
POPULATION FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS. AND IS ONE OF THE
LEADERS OF POLICIES THAT
ADDRESS IMMIGRANT INCLUSION
HEALTHEQUITY ECONOMIC JUSTICE
AND ENDING THE STATE'S
DETENTION TO DEPORTATION
PIPELINE. I WILL BE SPEAKING
MORE GENERALLY ABOUT THE
ONGOING NEEDS OF IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES SPECIFICALLY A
DOCUMENT CALIFORNIANS IN THIS
TOUCHES ON HEALTHCARE ECONOMIC
SECURITY AND ACCESS TO LEGAL
SERVICES. COBIT NINETEEN SHOWN
THAT DESPITE CALIFORNIA
LEADERSHIP. ON PROVIDING A
SAFETY NET FOR IMMIGRANTS OF
ALL STATUS LEVELS MORE CAN AND
NEEDS TO BE DONE. CURRENTLY THE
STATE PROVIDES MEDICAL COVERAGE
FOR ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN AND YOUNG
ADULTS. ANY THE ELIGIBILITY AS
THE YOUNG ADULT REACHES THE AGE
OF TWENTY SIX. WE ARE WORKING
WITH LEGISLATIVE CHAMPION SOME
OF WHO ARE HERE TODAY. TO
EXPAND MEDICARE COVERAGE TO ALL
INCOME ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. AND WHILE THE PANDEMIC
A SHIP GOING THAT THE MOST AT
RISK. UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS
SHOULD BE PRIORITIZED THE DATA
ALSO SHOWS THAT ARE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT
POPULATION. ARE JUST POOR
DISPROPORTIONATELY DYING AND
CONTRACTING CO BID AT A HIGHER
RATE THAN OTHER DEMOGRAPHIC
POPULATIONS IN THE STATE. THIS
YEAR THE STATE IS EXPANDING THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT TO
IMMIGRANT WORKERS WILL FILE
WITH AN INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER OR ITIN
RATHER THAN A SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER. AS SEPARATE WILL HELP
PROVIDE ECONOMIC SECURITY TO
MEMBERS OF OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY BUT IT SHOULD BE
LOOKED AT AS ONLY A START THIS
EXPANSION CONTINUES TO EXCLUDE
IMMIGRANTS. WORKING UNDER THE
TABLE ROLES ENTERPRISES OR WHO
ARE WORKING IN JOBS THAT DO NOT
PROVIDE WAGES SUCH AS CARE
GIVING TO FAMILY. CIBC'S HOPE
IS THAT THIS BODY CONTINUES TO
THINK YOUR POLICY. THAT CAN
PROVIDE ECONOMIC SECURITY. FOR
FOR THEM TO SEEK OUT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT IN THE WORKFORCE.
LASTLY AND PROBABLY MOST%
RELEVANT TO THE CONVERSATION
AROUND REUNIFICATION I WANT TO
TOUCH UPON THE IMMIGRATION
SERVICES PROGRAM THAT MYTH CAME
IN WITH SPOKE OUT IN PANEL ONE.
THE ONE CALIFORNIA PROGRAM HAD
IS IT AS IT IS KNOWN TO
ADVOCATES CURRENTLY PROVIDE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE BUDGET. FUNDING TO
COMMUNITY LEGAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THESE DOLLARS PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR EDUCATION OUT OF REACH. LOW
TO NO COST LEGAL SERVICES ON
ISSUES SUCH AS DACA INITIAL
APPLICATIONS AND RENEWALS.
DEPORTATION DEFENSE AND MANY
OTHER PROGRAMS. THE I. P. C.
AND OTHER ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE CDSS
WITH AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING TO
BE SPREAD OUT OVER THE NEXT TWO
YEARS. AND THIS FUNDING WOULD
ALLOW FOR THE STATE TO BE READY
ENACT RAPIDLY IN RESPONSE TO
POTENTIAL IMMIGRATION CHANGES.
FROM THE BINDING MINISTRATION.
THIS REQUEST IS BEING MADE AT
THE BEHEST OF THE LEGAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND WILL ALLOW THEM
TO ADDRESS REAP REUNIFICATION
EFFORTS. AND OTHER POTENTIAL
CHANGES SUCH AS DOC EXTENSIONS
AND A POTENTIAL PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP FOR THOSE THAT ARE
HERE. CIPC IS APPRECIATIVE OF
TODAY'S CONVERSATION LOOKS
FORWARD TO CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP. WITH MEMBERS OF
BOTH COMMITTEES STAFF AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS IN EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS FAMILY REUNIFICATION.
AND THE LARGER CONDITIONS THAT
MEET IMMIGRANTS COMING TO
CALIFORNIA FOR OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
THOMAS- OUR NEXT. PANELIST IS
WHEN TEACHERS LASKY CO FOUNDER
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
IMMIGRANT DEFENDERS LAWCENTER.
HI EVERYONE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HAVING ME THIS AFTERNOON-
AS WAS SAID I AM THE CO FOUNDER
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
IMMIGRANT DEFENDERS LAWCENTER
WE'RE ALSO KNOWN AS IN DEBT.
AND WE ARE ONE OF THE LARGEST
NONPROFIT DEPORTATION DEFENSE
PROVIDERS IN THE STATE ANNUALLY
WE SERVE MORE THAN SIXTEEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE IN REMOVAL
PROCEEDINGS WHO WOULD OTHERWISE
BE FORCED TO FACE AN
IMMIGRATION JUDGE ALONE
APPROXIMATELY HALF OF OUR
CLIENTS ARE CHILDREN WHO CAME
TO THE U. S. UNACCOMPANIED. AND
WERE DETAINED IN THE OFFICE OF
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT SHELTER
SYSTEM. WE ALSO PROVIDE
SERVICES INCLUDING ONE ON ONE
LEGAL CONSULTATIONS AND KNOW
YOUR RIGHTS CLASSES TO
APPROXIMATELY THIRTEEN HUNDRED
CHILDREN ANNUALLY. WERE
DETAINED IN- OUR SHELTERS IN
THE GREATER LOS ANGELES ORANGE
COUNTY AND INLAND EMPIRE REGION.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE LAUNCHED
THE FAMILY UNITY PROJECT IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE REPRESENTATION
TO FAMILIES THAT WERE SEPARATED
BY ZERO TOLERANCE. OUR PROJECT
HAS WORK TO REUNITE FAMILIES
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT AND REPRESENT THEM
IN THEIR ONGOING DEPORTATION
PROCEEDINGS. CURRENTLY WE
REPRESENT MORE THAN A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FAMILIES THAT WERE
FORMERLY SEPARATED BY ZERO
TOLERANCE. WE LEARNED TOO MANY
LESSONS FROM RESPONDING TO ZERO
TOLERANCE TO DEMONSTRATE GAPS
WE NEED TO FILL TO PROTECT THE
SILENCE SEEKING CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES GOING FORWARD. THE
FIRST ASPECT OF THAT WHICH I'LL
DISCUSS AND WHICH WAS TOUCHED
ON BY MY COLLEAGUE MS COOPER.
IN THIS IS OF CRUCIAL
IMPORTANCE IN PROTECTING
CHILDREN IN OUR STATE IS
STRENGTHENING THE LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS FOR- OUR OUR
SHELTERS OPERATING IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS WILL ENSURE
THAT WE AS A STATE ARE
WELCOMING UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN TO CALIFORNIA WITH
DIGNITY. IN MANY WAYS
CALIFORNIA'S AHEAD OF THE CURVE
WITH SOME OF OUR FACILITIES
WHEN COMPARED TO FACILITIES AND
OTHER STATES. BUT THAT DOES NOT
MEAN THAT THERE IS NOT ROOM FOR
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT. IT'S
OUR SUGGESTION THAT CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE TO BUILD UPON THE
STRONG FOUNDATION WE HAVE
INTERNALLY IS TO LEAD THE WAY
FOR THE REST OF THE COUNTRY AND
CARING FOR UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN IN A WAY THAT CENTERS
AND UP HOLDS THEIR DIGNITY AND
HUMANITY. IN ORDER TO DO THIS
CALIFORNIA SHOULD ENSURE THAT
THEIR SUFFICIENT OVERSIGHT OF
ALL ASPECTS OF ALL OUR OUR
FACILITIES IN THE STATE. I
STRENGTHENING LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS. X. ADJUSTERS
INCLUDE. CREATING A CLEAR
PREFERENCE FOR HOME BASED
PROGRAMS SUCH AS- ARE OURS
CURRENT TRANSITIONAL FOSTER
CARE PROGRAM RATHER THAN THE
CONGREGATE CARE SHELTER
FACILITIES A TRUCK TRANSITIONAL
FOSTER CARE PROGRAMS GIVES
CHILDREN AND- OUR CUSTODY THE
ABILITY TO LIVE WITH A FAMILY
IN OUR COMMUNITY ATTEND OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS WELL AWAITING
REUNIFICATION WITH THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS. FOR THOSE CHILDREN
RICH THEY MUST BE DETAINED IN A
CONGREGATE CARE FACILITY DUE TO
CAPACITY OR OTHER ISSUES
CALIFORNIA SHOULD LIMIT THE
SIZE OF THOSE FACILITIES TO
LESS THAN TWENTY FIVE CHILDREN
AND IT SHOULD BE SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNATED BUT THOSE SHELTER
SHOULD ONLY BE USED FOR SHORT
STAYS. LICENSING SHOULD FURTHER
BE UPDATED TO ENSURE THAT ONLY
QUALIFIED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS WITH A TRACK
RECORD OF PROVIDING CULTURALLY
COMPETENT SAFE CARE FOR
CHILDREN ARE A TEAM ABLE TO
OBTAIN NEW LICENCES VERSUS BUT
STILL IT'S- IN THE STATE. IN
THE ABSENCE OF THE STRONG
COMMONSENSE LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS CALIFORNIA COULD
FIND ITSELF IN THE SITUATION WE
DID IN TWENTY NINETEEN WHEN THE
OFFICE OF REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT
WAS CONSIDERING OPENING A
FACILITY IN THE VAN NUYS AREA
OF LOS ANGELES. THAT WOULD HAVE
DETAINED MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
CHILDREN IN ONE FACILITY RUN BY
A FOR PROFIT COMPANY WITH NO
TRACK RECORD OF PROVIDING CARE
FOR CHILDREN IN OUR STATE.
STEPS SHOULD BE TAKEN NOW TO
ENSURE THAT THIS POSSIBILITY IS
NEVER RACED AGAIN THANK YOU
CHAIRED MINISTRATIONS. I ALSO
WANT TO TOUCH ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF ENSURING INDEPENDENT
COMPETENT LEGAL REPRESENTATION
AND CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES
FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
WITHIN THE STATE- I WAS HAPPY
TO HEAR MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
THOMAS FROM THE I. P. C. SPEAK
ON. THE SPECIFICS OF ONE
CALIFORNIA FUNDING AND I WANT
TO. I REITERATE THE IMPORTANCE
OF CONTINUING TO INVEST IN
LEGAL SERVICES FOR FAMILIES
SEEKING ASYLUM. NOT ONLY IS IT
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THESE
FAMILIES WILL BE 11100% I'M NOT
LOOKING AT ZERO THERE
ACCIDENTALLY I MEAN 11100% MORE
LIKELY TO SUCCESSFULLY OBTAIN
PROTECTION IN OUR IMMIGRATION
COURTS THAT THEY HAVE A LAWYER.
BUT IT'S ALSO A KEY ENTRY POINT
AND LINKING FAMILIES NEW TO
CALIFORNIA TO COMMUNITY BASED
RESOURCES FOR HOUSING MEDICAL
CARE EDUCATION AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. WE ALSO WANT
TO POINT OUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
ENSURING MULTI YEAR FUNDING TO
LEGAL SERVICE PROVIDERS GIVEN
THAT DEPORTATION DEFENSE CASES
ALWAYS REMAIN OPEN FOR MORE
THAN A YEAR WELL IN MOST CASES
THEY DO. APPLE OF THE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY CASES THAT END UP
OPENED AS PART OF OUR FAMILY
UNITY PROJECT IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE OF THOSE FAMILIES
REMAIN IN DEPORTATION
PROCEEDINGS. AND REQUIRE
ONGOING CASE MANAGEMENT AND
REPRESENTATION. RECENT DATA
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF SYRACUSE
SHOWS THAT IMMIGRATION COURT
CASES LAST ON AVERAGE FOUR AND
A HALF YEARS BEFORE. MIGRANTS
HAVE THEIR DAY IN COURT. IT'S
VITALLY IMPORTANT THAT THE
FUNDING FOR NONPROFIT LEGAL
SERVICES TO PROVIDE
REPRESENTATION BE DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE CONTINUITY AND
STABILITY THAT WILL ALLOW FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF SUSTAINABLE
PROGRAMS THAT WILL ENRICH OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR YEARS TO COME.
THE LAST POINT I'D LIKE TO MAKE
UP IS AROUND ONE PORTENTS OF
BROADLY DEFINING FAMILY
SEPARATION TO INCLUDE
SUPPORTING ALL FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ALL INDIVIDUALS
WHO'VE BEEN VICTIMIZED. DUE TO
THE COLD POLICIES THE LAST THE
LAST FOUR YEARS. WE SHOULD NOT
BE LIMITING OUR RESPONSE AND
COMPASSION AS A STATE TO ONLY
THOSE VICTIMIZED BY THE
SPECIFIC POLICY OF ZERO
TOLERANCE. ITS MOST PRESSING IN
THIS MOMENT- CALIFORNIA FOR THE
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES WHO
REMAIN TRAPPED AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER AS PART OF THE REMAIN IN
MEXICO PROGRAM ALSO KNOWN AS
MPP AND OTHER BORDER POLICIES.
MANY FAMILIES OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS HAVE BEEN SUBJECTED TO
THIS DEADLY POLICY AND HAVE
BEEN SEPARATED AS A RESULT. IN
AS WE ACTUALLY SAW THE BY THE
MINISTRATION BEGAN THE FIRST
STEPS TO DISMANTLE THIS PROGRAM
LAST WEEK WE ANTICIPATE THAT
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WILL BE
PASSING OR BORDER PORTS OF
ENTRY AND MANY SETTLING HERE AT
THE STATE. AND THAT'S AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS ALL OF
BUT A LOT OF WAS ALSO- ON AN
EARLIER PANEL TODAY. ARE PART
OF THE NEWLY FORMED CALIFORNIA
WELCOMING TASK FORCE THAT IS
HELPING TO COORDINATE THE
SIGNIFICANT HUMANITARIAN AND
LEGAL RESPONSE THAT WILL BE
NEEDED TO WELCOME THESE
TRAUMATIZED FAMILIES INTO OUR
STATE. THERE WILL BE A
SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR THE STATE
TO PROVIDE FUNDING TO
ORGANIZATIONS PARTICIPATING IN
THE INITIAL RESPONSE TO THE
DISMANTLING. OF THE REMAIN IN
MEXICO PROGRAM AND ALSO TO
THOSE STATEWIDE WILL PROVIDE
ONGOING LEGAL REPRESENTATION IN
CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES. TO
THESE FAMILIES IN THE LONG
TERM. MY VERY LAST POINT IS
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT ALL IMMIGRATION
DETENTION AND ICE PRISONS IN
OUR STATE CAUSES FAMILY
SEPARATION. THEREFORE WE
IMPLORE LAWMAKERS TO SUPPORT
STATEWIDE EFFORTS TO END
IMMIGRATION DETENTION TO
PROVIDE STRONG REGULATION AND
OVERSIGHT OF FACILITIES FOR AS
LONG AS THEY CONTINUE TO EXIST
IN OUR STATE. AND TO SUPPORT
UNIVERSAL REPRESENTATION FOR
ALL DETAINED IMMIGRANTS SO THEY
CAN BE REUNITED WITH THEIR
FAMILIES AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR HAVING ME
TODAY. THANK YOU MAY. LUCKY
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY MISS COOPER MISTER
THOMAS MRS LASKY- I'D LIKE TO
OPEN IT UP TO ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. DO WE
HAVE ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO ASK A QUESTION.
OKAY. AT THIS POINT I'D LIKE TO
TURN TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION OF OUR HEARING. ALMONDS
ARE LIMITED TO TWO MINUTES
OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC- WHO WISH TO MAKE
COMMON. LADIES AND GENTLEMAN ON
THE PHONE LIKE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ATG OPERATOR WILL GIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER SO YOU CAN
MAKE YOUR COMMENT. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. OKAY FINANCE WE HAVE
NOBODY IN THE QUEUE- TURMAN
STONE- TO MAKE CLOSER REMARKS
IF YOU HAVE ANY. OKAY THANK
THIS IS A VERY INTERESTING
HEARING I THINK THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
CERTAINLY HAS BEEN TRACKING
OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS.
AND IT'S GOOD TO GET THIS
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT WE CAN
DO NEXT. ON THE TABLE AND FOR
US TO CONSIDER. I THINK THAT
THE MOST HELPFUL THING. IS THE
CHANGE IN TONE COMING OUT OF
WASHINGTON RIGHT NOW AND IF
THEY WILL. TAKE A SERIOUS RUN
AT ADDRESSING SOMEBODY
IMMIGRATION ERROR ISSUES. I
HAVE DEVELOPED OVER THE LAST
NUMBER OF YEARS AND I THINK
THAT MAKES. OUR JOB. EASIER BUT
IT IS DISHEARTENING TO SEE THE
DESTRUCTION THAT STILL EXISTS.
AND THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE AND
FAMILIES WHO ARE. BEING REALLY
TRAUMATIZED BY A GOVERNMENT
SYSTEM THIS IS NOT THE AMERICA
I THINK THAT WE ALL. EXPECT IN
THIS DAY AND AGE SO I THINK
THERE ARE SOME CLEAR
INDICATIONS OF THINGS WE NEED
TO BE DOING AND THERE STILL IS
A LOT MORE TO BE DONE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR RUNNING GREAT
HERE. THANK YOU TERMS THE- I
THANK YOU AGAIN TO ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS WHO SPOKE TODAY AND
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO JOINED US- THE FERRY'S BEEN
VERY LIMITED I APPRECIATE OUR
WITNESSES TAKING THE TIME TO
SHARE THEIR EXPERTISE
EXPERIENCES AND RECOMMENDATIONS
AS CLEAR THAT THE EXPERIENCE OF
FORCE FAMILY SEPARATION WILL
HAVE A LASTING IMPACT ON THESE
FAMILIES AS WELL AS ON THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THEY
CHOOSE TO SETTLE. WE'VE LEARNED
TODAY THAT TRAUMA CAN HAVE
LIFELONG ADVERSE EFFECTS IF
LEFT UNTREATED IN CALIFORNIA
MUST BE MINDFUL OF THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES FAMILIES FACE WHEN
DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING
SUPPORTS TO SERVE THEM I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT MORE
CALIFORNIA CAN DO TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR IMMIGRANT
POPULATION THANK YOU THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED.